Test.
[Music playing]
[music playing]
>> Hello, and welcome to Flutter
Live.
I'm Mark Aguinis
>> And I'm Emily Fortuna.
>> We are all things Flutter.
We are so happy you are joining
fuss for this jam packed two our
event.
>> I get to connect with people
from all over the world to make
their mobile app ideas possible.
And for today's event, we have
dozens of viewing parties
happening around the world,
including Estonia, Canada and
Angola.
Before too deep into Flutter
Live
content, Martin, where are you
here exactly?
>> I could ask you the same
thing.
>> Well, I'm part of the Flutter
team.  I have been a software
engineer on the Dart team for
five years.
You may recognize me from Google
IO or an YouTube like the
Flutter boring development show.
When I'm not being a computer
scientist, I'm an  actor and
improviser.  Yeah.
>> Well, I'm on the Flutter team
here at Google and I have been
on the team for a year and a
half, starting back when we were
in alpha.  You might be familiar
with my voice on
the introducing Flutter video or
talks at GG China and Google
Marketing live.  And we will be
showing you around the venue and
bringing exclusive live content
including interviews, demos and
more.
>> Flutter Live is a global
celebration
of Flutter, and there will be
things we can't share  yet, the
functionality of Flutter as well
as the ecosystem.
>> Starting with some fun facts
about Flutter.
Did you know that the Flutter
and Dart mascot is called Dash
and there were over 2,000 of
them  created today.
>> Very cool. Flutter has been
in development for four years.
>> And actually before it was
called
Flutter, the original name was
Skyy.
>> I like Flutter better.
>> Do you know what country has
the largest number of developers
of Flutter?
>> Yeah, it's China.
>> Nice. Martin, do you want to
share a fun fact about yourself
with us?
>> Well, one of the first brands
to use
Flutter was Ham ill Hamilton,
the Broadway musical.  I'm
somewhat obsessed with it.
>> Somewhat obsessed.
>> I've memorized every lyric.
>> Show us.
>> The ten daughter without a
father,
working a lot harder by being a
lot
smartedder by being a
self-starter by 14.  And they
place in the charge of the
chart.
>> Hamilton is one of the most
talked about and most loved
musicals inland and Broadway and
around the around.  We wanted to
make the show more accessible to
develop an app to meet the needs
of fans as we started to expand
the brand.
We turned to Posse, a New
York-based development firm.
>> Hamilton's app launched three
months after writing the code.
Fans can enter a daily lottery,
buy merchandise for a commerce
experience, take selfie photos
and get daily news and updates.
>> We knew the app needed to be
rock
solid and really represent the
amazing Spencer that the
Hamilton show itself provides.
And ultimately that's why we
decided to use Flutter.
>> Flutter is a mobile UI
toolkit that
allows developers and designers
to craft
beautiful native experiences on
iO S and Android and it's open
source.
>> We have high expectations of
quality.
We expect pixel-perfect results
and need them to be high
performers.  Flutter gave us
opportunities that previously
wasn't available to us.
The fact that it was a single
codebase, we could be consistent
across platforms.  Extendability
to produce more features.
>> It allowed me to make changes
fast and iterate without having
to stop and restart the app.
Coming from an iOS and Android
with
background, it's what I've been
waiting for.
The community helped us
integrate elements of Firebase
and Cloud.
>> We are happy we found Flutter
to build these for iOS and
Android.
>> We turned the app around
faster than I could have
imagined.  We were able to make
changes right up to the night we
went live and really feel
confident about them.  In fact,
we pushed an  entirely new
feature to the app store the day
before we launched.
>> And since launch, Flutter's
speed helped us build new
features such as the trivia
game.
As the show grows, we can keep
pace with a ton of new features
to make the app better.
>> We couldn't be more thrilled
with Flutter.
We have used one codebase to
deliver a
high-quality app that Hamilton
fans have fallen in love with.
>> The entire brand of Hamilton
is about an experience for fans
they're thrilled
about the new features and we're
excited about where the app goes
next.
>> Mobile users expect their
apps to
have beautiful designs, smooth
animations and great
performance.  To deliver on
this, developers need to create
new features faster than ever
without compromising on quality
or performance.  That's why we
built Flutter.
Flutter is Google's mobile UI
framework that provides a fast
and expressive way for
developers to build
native apps on both iOS and
Android.  This is because apps
and interfaces made with Flutter
are built from a
single codebase, compiled to
code and
use the GPU and access
platforms and services.  Three
ways that Flutter helps you on
day one.  Engineered for high
developer velocity.  Stateful
hot reload, you can change the
code and see it come to life in
less than a second without
losing the state of the app.
It ships with customizable
widgets built from the modern
reactive framework.  Plus
popular development tools so you
can get started quickly with the
editor or IDE you know and love.
Flutter moves the
widgets,  rendering, and
gestures into the framework to
give you complete control over
every pixel on the screen.  You
have flexibility to build custom
designs.
Flutter apps have platform
conventions and details such as
scrolling, icons, fonts and
more.
Apps with Flutter are on the app
store and Google Play
stereotype.  If you're new to
mobile, Flutter gives
you a fast, fun and modern way
to deliver native  apps.  As an
experienced developer, you can
add Flutter to the existing
tools to
build new,  expressive UIs.
It's free and open source and
used by developers and
organizations around the
world including enterprise,
agencies and startups.  Visit
Flutter.io to get started today.
We can't wait to see what you
are going to build.
>> I'm here with Nilay, one of
the program managers on the
Flutter team and also one of the
key people working on building
up our Flutter community.
Nilay, you have done an amazing
job at building up the Flutter
community all around the world.
I am seriously impressed.  And I
wanted to ask you a little bit
more about how you got involved
with  that.
>> I actually have a story about
how I started working with
Flutter.  So, I was working with
the developer communities in
another team at Google.
And then so, with those
communities they are trying to
learn about Google technologies,
they are running meetups, they
are asking some resources.  And
all of a sudden, the community
started asking about  Flutter.
Oh, we need some speakers for
Flutter.  Can we get some
resources for Flutter?  Oh, what
is that Flutter?  I should look
at that.  Basically the
community attracted me about the
Flutter and I just looked into
that.  It was a great team.  I'm
so happy being in this team.
>> What do you take into
building a developer community?
Do you have any advice?
>> Building a community is not
an easy job, but also not
impossible.  It's all about
bringing the right people
together.  So, if you want to
build a community around
something, you just have to find
the people that is going to
create the foundation of your
community.  They are the people
who is sharing the same
interests and shared values and
they are trying to do something
with your technology.  This will
be the group of people that are
going to set the tone of the
community and the standards of
the community.
>> You work with the women tech
leaders I believe.
Can you tell us a little bit
about your involvement with
them?
>> I was running community
events for everyone.
We were looking for speakers, we
got little response from women.
But the first women tech makers
in Istanbul, I got 50 speakers.
Why didn't these women submit
for the other conference?  And
this kind of thing is happening,
and we want to feel more
encouraged, more empowered.  So,
they are participating.
>> Agreed. Nilay, thank you so
much for talking with me.  This
is great.
>> Hi, I am an engineer and I'm
organizing a Flutter meetup.  I
was introduced to Flutter in
2017 and it changed my life.
Now, the software that fits you.
I can change one piece and take
it live on the device.  And I
don't have to wait two minutes
anymore.
To make Flutter even better, I
karatted some patches such as
preview, slight, sticky, and
most importantly, side kick.
I can create complex apps more
easily with Flutter than with
others.  That's magic of
Flutter.
For example, I was  creating
this app.  To go to Flutter
Live.  These animations are
entirely programmed on Flutter.
My favorite part of Flutter is
that
what I saw on my phone is what
my users see.
It matches the device and
matches what is produced.
And Flutter is a  fast, growing,
vibrant community.
And thanks to Flutter, the
future of
unified development is
happening!
>> Here we are inside the
science museum IMAX.  The
Flutter keynote is about to
happen.  Let's look at the
stage.  This is a pretty cool
design.  And this screen is
huge.  It's so big that you can
fit four double decker buses on
top of each other.
Or if we were to lay this thing
flat, you could park 64 taxis on
it.  I'm so excited for this
keynote to begin.
But before it does, let's take a
brief
look at the rest of the venue as
we set up.  Here we are in front
of registration where all the
onsite attendees are checking
in.
After the keynote, in this
space, we have cool demos and
activations to show you.  Let's
look at a few of them.  All the
way in the back of the room, a
massive showcase wall with 99
phones that have Flutter apps
loaded on  them.  If you want to
check out the apps on the phone,
go to flutter.io-showcase.  And
we have the  #askflutter show.
Andrew from our team is
answering your questions after
the show.  What are you looking
at?
>> Looking the at Tweet for ask
Flutter.
Jose asked how to use a white
status bar with a Material app
bar.
>> Actually the Material app bar
should style the status for you,
but you can set it yourself with
Chrome.
>> It looks like the show
technically already started.
But most of the questions will
be answered right after the
keynote.
Make sure to stay tuned and ask
all your questions using
#askflutter.
>> We'll be waiting.
>> Thanks.
>> Hello, I live in Israel, I'm
a co-founder.  I switched to
Flutter from JavaScript and PHP.
Having only typed code, it's a
game changer.  Hard to go back.
We are using Flutter to rebuild
native mobile apps, from three
to two.  It's a massive win,
we're a small team.  My favorite
part of Flutter is the
amazing productivity it enables.
We are accomplishing in months
what was taking years.
>> And now Eric Seidel, you were
on the Chrome team when this
came to be.  You have seen it go
from an idea to now, you know, a
globally-used framework.  I'm
curious, what was your initial
vision with Flutter and how has
that changed, if anything, and
evolved.
>> Yeah, Flutter started out
with a very different purpose
than it has now.  Flutter
started out as just trying to
make the web better.  We were
tries to make Chrome better,
trying to make Chrome smaller.
And when we first started
Flutter, we took a couple weeks
and we took a razor to Chrome,
we said.  We even called the
test results that we came up
with "Razor.
"  And we cut down Chrome and
tried to make it fast and small
and remove some of the sharp
edges that the weapon has
developed over many, many years.
Anyway, we ended up with a
faster web, but that wasn't
sufficient.  We wanted to do
more and we ended up adding more
and more and more.  And once you
add things, you're no longer on
the web.  We have rewritten the
system maybe
three times  since, but what we
have now is Flutter.
>> Great. So, what we have now,
obviously, has been used all
over the world.
But I'm curious along that
adoption journey was there a
moment when you went, wow.  This
is legitimate.  This is really
taking off.
>> I think the biggest moment
for me was Hamilton.  When we
saw the Hamilton app ship, when
we saw that team be successful
with Flutter.
We had seen teams be successful
inside Google for several years.
But seeing folks that we had
much less ability to, you know,
talk to on a
minute-to-minute basis be
successful with this technology
helped me belief that, yeah,
anybody can use that.
>> That's great. I know now
they have over a million
installs and a lot of people are
winning tickets through the app.
$10 tickets.  That's  great.
Where do you see Flutter headed
in the future?
>> One of the things that we're
seeing with Flutter is we're
seeing people take Flutter to
more places.  We, you know,
started with iOS and Android
because that's where so many
developers are today.
But we have seen people bring
Flutter to desktop.  We have
seen people experiment with
Flutter on all sorts of sizes
and shape of devices and I'm
really excited to, you know,
light up more Devs as that
continues.
>> Awesome. Well, thank you so
much, Eric.
>> Oh, hi, I'm Phillip I from
the Flutter team, I'm here to
introduce the boring show.
It's where two engineers sit
down and build apps in Flutter
from scratch.  The show is
unedited, you see the mistakes,
all the dead ends and how we get
out of them.  It's an
opportunity for you see Flutter
being used in more complicated
apps.
We take viewer suggestions on
what features and had apps to
build next.
If you have a lot of time and
like
boring things like watching
butter melt
or doing your  taxes, you'll
love this show.
>> Hey, I'm Martin and standing
here
with Tao and Ja young from our
UX research team at Google.  I
want to start with asking you,
what
do you do at UX in Google and
specifically with Flutter.
>> UX in general is trying to
make sure our product
development is centered around
user needs and make sure they
are usable and useful.  But our
work on Flutter is a little bit
different from general UX
because we work on a developer
product and we try to make sure
the team understands that
programming and active
development is an inherently
human process and human
activities.
We want to make sure the
features, the API and design we
implement satisfies the needs
and allows the developer to move
as fast as they could without
frictions and seams when they
use our tools.
>> Could you maybe share with us
a recent study you have done as
part of using the effort.
>> I have been running Flutter
user survey.  Thanks all for
participating in.  We've learned
a lot from our users and our
main goal is to bridge the gap
between our users and engineers
to help the engineers prioritize
their time and effort in
developing Flutter.
>> In doing these types of
things, was there something that
was surprising or
shocking as you did these
research projects?
>> Yeah, we had a recent
experiment where we looked at
different ways to improve our
messages.  And many of the
community members actually
participated in this experiment.
Thank you for your
participation.  But one thing we
found is that  adding
a little bit of styling in the
error
message like color or structure
and omitting some of the details
can greatly
improve the error message
comprehension by sometimes 30%.
By having the guidelines to make
sure Flutter's error messages
are more usable
and easier to understand in the
future.
>> What motivates you personally
to work on Flutter every day?
>> I think that Flutter is an
open source project, it's
awesome.  And the engineers from
Google and the community members
also at Google work together to
create this app called Flutter.
It's awesome.
>> Thank you, I have had the
privilege of working with you
guy on some of these as well.
Thank you for sharing and thank
you
for sharing some of your work.
>> Oh, hi there, I'm a Flutter
developer, I'm also the CTO at
Zumbai.  Flutter has changed the
way I code.
I previously developed products
and then an iOS app.  As a
developer, I don't want to
maintain two apps.
Flutter changed the way I build
both apps at once.  And it's
native, I don't have to worry
about cross-platform.  And I
love how fast it is to develop
Flutter.  I like hot reload.
This building the app instantly
is like magical.  One of the
great things I like about the
Flutter community is that when
you
go on to the hub, you can find
all sorts of great tutorials and
components that you can actually
use in your projects right
there.  This is a great way for
a community to build and it's
one of the first signs that the
technology that you're using is
very, very valuable.  So, with
that, I think  Flutter's going
to be an amazing tool for the
coming years and it's going to
be one of
the best ways to build mobile
apps.
>> On today's advisers, apps
rarely get
a neat rectangle to run in,
controls can
come in and controls nip at the
content, complicating layouts
with.  There is safearea.  It
changes the screen and pads the
shell to match.  If your app
looks like this, wrap it
in a safearea and keep your
content safe on both iOS and
Android.  You can specify which
dimensions you care about.  And
wrapping the body of a scaffold
works great.
For more area on SafeArea and
the
other Flutter widgets, head to
flutter.io.
>> If you could hat reload
anything in your life, what
would it be?
>> I would want to hot reload
the sending  Dashes to the
community.  Because there are so
many people from so many
countries that I want to have a
Dash.  And I was like, it's not
so easy to ship a  Dash to that
one.
So, I would want to hot reload
that one.
>> One of the things that is
helpful is to eliminate the long
time.  But if I could broaden
that
capabilities to my life, I wish
I could
have hot reload for the Bay area
traffic
so I can get home sooner and get
to work sooner in the morning.
>> The time that my husband ate
that
lobster roll and he was sick on
vacation.
I would change has lobster roll
to false, definitely.
>> I would have my coffee this
morning.
>> If you could hot reload
anything in your life, what
would it be?
>> Well, I think it would have
to be weight loss.
I skip breakfast, I lose 20
pounds!
>> Hey you. Yeah, you. You're
in this because you're curious
about Flutter, yeah?  The
conversation doesn't just go one
way.
The  #flutterlive.
>> We are open source and this
event is no different.  We will
be responding to comments in
real-time.
>> Let's look at what people
have been posting in the leadup
to this event.
Samuel says FYI, I'll be
watching
Flutter Live on December # 4th.
>> [speaking in Spanish --
#flutterlive.
] throughout the live stream, we
will be jumping back to show the
Tweets coming in during Flutter
Live.  And huge shoutout to
those hosting viewing parties.
>> Oh, and speaking of social
media, if you would like to
connect with the
Flutter team, follow us on
Twitter @flutterio.  Or check
out the YouTube channel.
>> And check out the community
section of  putter.io for more
info.
>> I'm here with Maurice, a
software engineer on the Flutter
team.  He's particularly focused
on the plugins and ecosystem
part of Flutter.
So, I know that you've worked a
lot on the Firebase  plugins.
Is there a particular Firebase
plugin that you think is
especially underappreciated that
should have some more love?
More usage?
>> I like the Firebase plugin.
With that plugin, it makes it
really easy to navigate to the
part of your app that you really
like.  And combined with
Flutter's route and how easy it
is to navigate with Flutter,
I think it fits really well
inside that ecosystem.
>> So, how would you combine
dynamic links with the route in
Flutter?
>> Go to the website, get your
configuration file for Android
or iOS.  Just plug that in and
include the dependency in your
spec and everything.  Then after
that, all you have to do is just
retrieve the dynamic link and
just parse it.  And then you can
use the navigation with pushes
and routes to set up automatic
navigation when your app starts.
So, it's really just
straightforward to implement.
>> Do you have any advice for
people looking to create new
plugins or packages for Flutter?
>>> I would look at the language
guide for effective Dart.
Looking at that language guide
really help use not only learn a
lot about Dart and all its
features.
It helps you write cleaner code.
And looking at the language
guide
helps your app get a lot more
exposure for following the
guides.  When we run the test on
the plugin website, we run
through Dart format and how you
implement it.
>> That's true. And I know that
the score that you see on the
package on pub when you're
looking at packages is partly
based on if it's following style
guides.
>> That's true. It basically
running Dart format, a plugin
tool you can use to
automatically format your code.
And then make sure all your
dependencies are used, they're
lined up and other checks as
well.
>> Makes your code more readable
as well.  Is there any package
or plugin that you would like to
see that doesn't exist yet?
>> For me, I would definitely
like to see a plugin for a
graphics engine.
Right now for my own personal
projects, making it with the
Flame
plugin, a really basic 2D
graphics engine.  I would like
to see a fully fleshed out one.
That would be great for a lot of
developers.
>> Maurice, thank you so much
for chatting with us.  It's been
great.
>> Hi, my name is Paul from
Tanzania.  I'm the co-founder
and lead product manager.
I fell in love with Flutter from
the
time I saw Emily coding on
Google IO.  With Flutter, it's
really easy to bring my ideas to
life and coming up
with working prototypes to share
with my team and users and get
instant feedback.  And I have
been working on a product that's
basically a recorder app for up
and coming artists to share
ideas with the community.
So, using Flutter to build it,
it was interesting do come up
with an idea and a working
prototype to share with the team
as well as our users and for
them to give us instant feedback
on this project.
The parts I really like about
Flutter are, one, the
development cycle.  Using hot
reload and hot  restart, it was
easy to see an idea come to
life.  The second thing I really
like about Flutter is the
packages.  Now, I'm a bit of a
lazy coder.  I prefer to kind
something that already works and
plug it into my project.  And
finally,
the community.
I really, really enjoy the
community engagement on Twitter
as well as on GitHub.  That is
my Flutter development story.
Thank you.
>> What kind of widget are you
and why?
>> I think I am a feature
builder because I'm building the
community and connecting the
people.
>> That's great.
And also because you're
responding to peoplearound the
world, it's an asynchronous
request.  Great answer.
>> What type of widget are you
and why?
>> That's a really good
question.  I think I would like
to be the scaffold widget.  I
think it's included in the
default template.  What I would
like to do is use the better
scaffolding experience to make
sure how to help people that
understand different concepts
and widgets they need
to use to create a better and
better experience for their
users.
>> What kind of widget are you
and why?
>> It would definitely be the
stack.  The stack is the widget
where you're trying to stack
some widgets over another one.
And for me that really resonates
because I'm always trying to
find time
for everything in my life and
that stack is pretty similar to
that.
>> I think I would have to be
styling.
Because I like to make my
clothes and I dress kind of
oddly and I wear funky jewelry.
So, that's -- that feels right.
>> I'm theme. Everything that I
touch gets more beautiful.  But
I don't like the idea that I
would have to have a child.  I'm
the baby.
>> Almost every Flutter layout
uses rows and columns.  And
they're pretty cool.
They can hug their children
tightly or spread them out and
relax.  But what if you would
like one of those children to
stretch and fill the extra
space?
Just wrap it in an expanded
widget and watch it grow.
When a row or column lays out
its children, it does the
inflexible ones first, then
divides the remaining space
among the unflexible once like
expanded.  You can set a factor
just in case of competition.
For more info on expanded and
all the
other Flutter widgets, head to
flutter.io.
>> Here are the top five things
people love about Flutter.
>> First off, stateful hot
reload.  This allows you to make
changes in your app and see them
appear in action in less than a
second.  Developers building
with Flutter complain that they
don't have time to go get coffee
or make tea because their builds
are too fast.  In the unlikely
event that hot reload is
unsufficient, a hot restart of
your app also only takes a few
seconds and you're back in
action.
>> Writing a separate iOS and
Android
app has the possibility of twice
as many bugs and twice as much
code to test and maintain.
It can be hard that open are
each app has feature parity as
it degrees.
With Flutter, it's a single
codebase, speed up development
and making test coverage easier.
>> Flutter aims to provide 60
frames per
second with smooth, jank-free
animations.  It's compiled ahead
of time, the Flutter engine is
executing machine instructions
for lightning fast performance.
>> An app with Flutter has a
great
collection of built-in
components for the platform.
There's no need to learn two
different development systems to
make your app feel natural to
your users.
>> If it looks good on this
device, will it look good on
this other phone?  If it's
written in Flutter, the answer
is yes.
Flutter uses the engine to draw
the entire UI to screen.
All components are performant
and provides consistent from
device to device.
>> Let us know what your
favorite feature is.
>> Hi, any name's Rona, I'm in
Denver,  Colorado.  I'm fairly
new to Flutter.
I have only been working with
for two months.
Prior to that, I was doing web
app development for the past 18
years.
Mostly on the UI, UX and
frontend development side of
things.
The last several years, I was in
a leadership role and not so
much coding.  And I decided that
missed it.  And I was ready to
dive back in.  One of the things
I didn't have any experience
with was mobile app development.
We didn't do mobile app
development at the agency where
I was working.  So, I decided
now is as good a time as
any and I quit my job and now
I'm ready to build my own thing.
I'm building my own mobile app
and I'm doing it with Flutter.
I spent some time, I looked at
the alternatives.
I looked at Swift, I looked at
React Native.  But really
nothing offered what Flutter
could offer.  The hot reloading,
the ready-made widgets.  I was
up and running very  quickly.
And best of all, what
I loved the most about Flutter
is the community.
Hands down, it is the best
development community I have
ever been a part of.
I was welcomed so quickly and
warmly, there's so much help.
There's a lot of active,
wonderful people in all the
different networks and it's been
wonderful.  No question is a
dumb  question.  Got access to
really smart people.  It's just
been a joy.  I can't wait to see
where Flutter goes.  That's my
Flutter story.
>> What is something you wish
your younger self knew?
>> I wish I knew I would be
standing in front of the camera
someday.
>> All right.
>> Well, I used to work for
Steve Jobs at Next  Computers
which was the company he started
up after he was kind of tossed
out of Apple.  And what I wish I
knew is that when I
quit right as they went back to
rejoin
Apple, they offered to either
pay me  $10,000 in cash or
convert it to Apple stock.  And
I did the cash.  It was before
the iPhone.  I wish I knew that.
>> Regrets.
>> What's something you wish
your younger self knew?
>> How I really looked with that
goatee.
I shouldn't have done it.
>> Flutter has a lot of widgets
to help with explicit an Mesas.
Ones that you, the developer,
code up.  Before there are also
implicit animations, those that
change for you.  A good one to
know is animated container.  You
can build it once with a
particular attribute like color.
And when you rebuild it with a
different value, say in response
to a set state call, animated
container performs a linear
interpolation between the two
values.
And it's more than just two
colors you
can animate borders, border
radii, background images, width,
height, alignment and more.  The
length is  controlled by the
duration parameter and you can
specify your own curve to
customize the effect.
There are a bunch of other
widgets to help with the
implicit animation too.  Head to
flutter.io.
>> Hello. I'm Kelsey from
Austin, Texas.
I'm a web developer and I work
in Rails.  But previously on
Cordova.  I really like Flutter
because of the hot reloading.  I
like that it integrates into VS
code
easily and I can run my app from
there.  I like the Firebase
integration
because I usually use Firebase
for my projects and it's
super-easy to get started with
Flutter.  I also really like the
Flutter community on Twitter.
And I went to a Flutter camp in
New York City and had the best
time.  Everyone was
super-welcoming.  And it was a
lot of fun.  I haven't started
my own project yet,
but I've contributed to a few
open source projects and am
excited about getting started to
build something of my own soon.
>> Hello, I'm here with Shams,
the
technical writer for Flutter and
the chief plushy officer.  Tell
me, what are the
responsibilities of the chief
plushy officer and how did you
get that title?
>> It was given to me by another
colleague.  I had some designs
for the mascot.  And I found a
company to make them.
And then we were making them for
Dart Conf 2018 in January.
I named her Dash because that
was the first code the project
name for Dart.
>> That's great.
And I think you have some Dashes
to show us.
>> I do. Here is the first
Dash.  And you can see she's got
some sort of
turquoise, light turquoise here
and here.
After she was made, there were
tweaks
to the Flutter logo where it was
brought more in line with
Material design.  And so, the
turquoise went away.
And so, our second one has --
has blue.  Like a darker blue
substituted for the light color.
But is otherwise essentially the
same.
And then I was requested to make
-- to make some puppets.  So, I
did.  I made a puppet.
Everything's a widget!  You
know?
>> Why is Dash a bird?
>> Oh, an early O'Reilly book
about Dart on the cover had a
hummingbird.  And it was a very
angular, spikey hummingbird.
But when the design company that
designed the Dart Conf website
for us,
they made this fat, round bi so,
also, I've had Dash socks made.
And --
>> Those are adorable.
>> And I've had Dash fabrics
made.
So, here I have a chiffon I plan
to make into a scarf.
And here I have a knitted --
some knitted fabric that I was
going to make
into a top to wear at Flutter
Live, but people have suggested
that it should be  a -- like a
onesie.  An adult onesie.  I
don't know.  I'll think about
that.
>> Thank you so much, Shams.
It's been great talking with
you.
>> Thanks.
It's been fun talking with you
too.
>> Hey, my name is Mark
Thompson.  I'm from Chicago,
Illinois.  And I'm a software
engineer and an entrepreneur.
Flutter has changed the way I
develop really because of the
fact that I've never really
developed with a bird by my side
all the  time.  A Flutter
project that I'm really excited
about, really proud of is the
app that I have been making
called Totally Strong.  It's a
fitness app.  And I told Flutter
because I really wanted to see
if I could do some really great
things with a new and up and
coming technology that promised
this idea of great speed and
great development.  So, I made
Totally Strong.  My favorite
thing about development
with Flutter has to be the
development and the hot reload.
What I like about the Flutter
community is the support from
the development team and the
community of developers.  I have
noticed that even when I was
first learning how to do
Flutter, there were so many
people, even from the Google
team, who were willing to try to
help me
out.  People were responding on
Twitter, responding in the
Gitter.  People were just all
around.  And that was
super-fantastic.  And the
community is no different.  The
other people in the community
really want to see you do well
and really want to help where
they can.  So, that is
phenomenal.  I think that this
is just going to make Flutter go
all the way to the top.  I'm
really excited about it.
>> I'm here with Will Larche who
works on Material design and
Flutter.  Tells what that means.
>> Sure, I'm the Flutter
engineering lead in Material.
Material has a huge engineering
team
that works on Material
components on different
platforms and also supports the
different platform team like
Flutter as they're building out
anything that has to do design.
So, I work with Material
designers and I work with
Flutter engineers to make sure
that there is really good,
really easily executable,
beautiful design in Flutter.
>> That's amazing. I remember
at IO earlier this year,
Flutter was one of the four
first-class implementations of
Material alongside
Android, web and iOS.  I was
wonder for you could comment a
little bit about that.
>> Yeah. That still blows me
away.  It's still exciting to be
in that group.
Those are some giants of digital
industry and Flutter is that
important now.  So, we support
it with our documentation by
having an engineering team and
we believe that this time we
will be growing with the
platform instead of having to
catch up.  And that's a really
great place to be.  Also, we're
really grateful to the Flutter
team for the material
implementation that they have
built.  It is spot on and it's
amazing and
being the default UI library for
a platform is really flattering.
Like we're really, really
grateful that people understand
how material design makes
beautiful things easily.  And
now that we see how Flutter
makes any kind of app easily,
those two things go together
perfectly.
>> What really motivates you
every day to work on Flutter?
>> I was assigned to Flutter
kind of just to do a little bit
of an exploration in Material.
I was working on the iOS team at
the time.  And almost instantly
I knew that I did not want to do
anything but Flutter ever again
for the rest of my career.
Every day is a delight building
with Flutter.  And it's very
exciting to be on the ground
level of the next big thing.
>> Awesome.
Well, I didn't want to leave
this interview without asking,
did I miss the memo?  Should I
be wearing a suit?
>> You should be wearing a suit.
You should be wearing a suit
every day.
>> Awesome. Thanks so much,
Will.
>> Thanks, Martin.
>> #fluttererlive keynote is
happening soon.
>> #askflutter, how does fade
and image work?
>> Martin, we're supposed to be
answering those questions.
>> How does fade and image work?
>> Actually, I made a YouTube
video about that.  It's in our
widget of the week series.  This
is a friendly reminder to share
your questions and thoughts with
the #askflutter and Flutterlive.
>> Andrew who you may have seen
on the Google developer YouTube
channel will be live to answer
questions from our online
viewers.
Your Tweets with those hashtags
can appear on the show.
>> We're happy to hear from you.
On to the show and see you on
the other side.
>> You never know in advance
when you
have the next idea for a song.
And when you have an idea, you
don't know if it's going to make
it into the song.  It's
important, we can use it to
record and organize our ideas at
any time from anywhere.
>> We've been innovating music
recording
process ever since the studio
has been built.
Maybe not just for the Beatles,
we
shouldn't forget, and the other
partist
from Pink Floyd to the latest
and the greatest.  And we have
been looking at the music
writing process and we can see
how it changed.  And we noticed
that people are coming up with
their ideas, their song ideas,
at the worst possible moments.
So, we wanted to develop
something to
make that initial spark easily
captured
to make sure that they get those
ideas.
>> Having all that in mind, we
created a
user-friendly, very
minimalistic-looking iOS app.
Artists can use it to record in
the app.
>> People were asking for two
things, one is a version and
then asking for Android.  And
there were so many of our
requests.  All of our Facebook,
all of our Instagram, all of our
Tweets that we just had to
develop it very, very quickly.
>> And we opened up a set, okay,
we can do it.
But it wasn't as easy as we
expected.
While the app itself was simple,
it has a very complicated search
inside so
we have to look into innovative
solutions to get to topline on
Android quickly.  After some
research, we found Flutter.
>> Flutter is a free and open
source SDK  created by Google.
It has a single codebase, allow
you to crack native apps on iOS
and Android at the same time.
One of the key features is
stateful hot reload.  This
allows developers to make
changes while the app is running
in real-time.
Speeding up the troubleshooting
immensely.
And there are  customizable
widgets to create beautiful
interfaces.
>> We used a widget to create a
swipe menu.
Overall, the implementation was
very, very simple.  We were able
to develop the Android version
in just ten weeks with a small
team consisting of two  people,
one
Android and two frontend
developers.
>> As we wanted to Democratize
music
making, it was good to have the
app available.  We are excited
our app is available on both iOS
and Android.
>> Topline has made making songs
so much  easier.  It has become
a vital part in our creative
process.  And we're looking
forward to making
much more songs with it in the
future.
[ Applause ]
And now, please welcome to the
stage, Tim Sneath.
TIM: Thank you so much.
Welcome to Flutter Live!  Thank
you all for coming.  This is a
global event.  We have hundreds
of thousands of
people watching this all over
the world.
Whether by  livestream, or at
the over 150 viewing parties
around the world.  Whether
you're watching us over a
morning cup of coffee in
Seattle, or whether you're
attending this meeting after
work in Berlin.
Or joining a Pajama party in
Bangkok, welcome.
I want to start by paying credit
to the many software engineers
who contributed to this project.
And without whom we wouldn't all
be here today.  With Flutter, we
assembled the best engineering
talent from across the industry.
All of whom shared a dream of
reinventing how user interfaces
are built.  Our team includes
leaders with
pedigree from web, desktop and
mobile UI toolkits.  It includes
the former editor of the HTML
standard.  Leading developers
who worked on WebKit and Blink.
And architects who created the
first version of V8,
the JavaScript engine that
powers Chrome.  And beyond our
own team, we also have hundreds
of contributors from the
community.  We've identified
issues, contributed patches, and
even introduced new  features.
And all of that has brought us
to this moment today.  This
isn't just our products, but
it's your products.  And we're
so proud to be part of the
journey with you.
So, let's talk about Flutter.
Our vision for Flutter is
something that many of us have
been dreaming of for years.
A powerful, general purpose,
open UI toolkit for  building
stunning
experiences on any device.
Embedded, mobile, desktop, or
beyond.  While we're still in
the early stages of this
journey, we're already depending
on Flutter ourselves at Google
to power many different apps and
services.  We know, from direct
experience, that it's ready for
beautiful production apps.
And now, we're delighted to
share it with you also.
Our immediate focus is the
mobile phone.  Developers today
are forced
to compromise between either
building
the same app multiple times on
multiple
operating systems, or accepting
a lowest common denominator
solution that trades native
speed and accuracy for
portability.  With Flutter, the
days of compromise are finally
over.
There are four characteristics
of Flutter that we think make it
a unique
platform for you to build native
mobile application experiences.
Firstly, Flutter enables you to
build beautiful  apps.  As
you'll hear later, Flutter
provides a rich palette of tools
that give you
control over every pixel on the
screen.  Designers will never
again have to compromise on
their vision.  Flutter includes
a full set of widgets that
deliver  pixel-perfect
experiences on both iOS and
Android.
And it enables the ultimate
realization of material design.
So, whether you're building a
highly-tailored, branded
experience, or a native iPhone
or Android app, you should find
that Flutter provides everything
you need to
build a beautiful, award-winning
interface.  Secondly, Flutter is
fast.
It's powered by the blazing
speed Skia
2D graphics engine which enables
hardware accelerated graphics.
From the start, we architected
Flutter
to be able to support
glitch-free, jank-free graphics
at the native speed of your
display.  Flutter code is
compiled.  It's not interpreted.
It doesn't go through a virtual
machine.  When you're
application is finished,
it's compiled to native machine
code.
Thirdly, Flutter is productive.
Flutter introduces a
revolutionary new capability for
developers and designers to
iterate on their apps in
real-time.
And we call this stateful hot
reload.  And it  enables you to
change the code
of your app and see the change
changes in real-time without
restarting the app.
And we think stateful hot reload
transforms the way you use the
app.  And developers, some in
the room today, say it makes
them up to three times more
productive.  And lastly, Flutter
is
open.  Flutter itself is open
source.  Open for contributions.
Open for extensibility.  Every
line of code is available for
you to read, fork, extend,
amend.  You don't have to buy a
developer tool
to use Flutter or use its tools.
Everything is licensed freely
under a BSD-style license.  And
that openness extends to the
community.  There are already
thousands of Flutter plugins out
there.  And, of course, anything
with the underlying operating
system is exposing is available
to Flutter.
Whether it's written in Kotlin
or
Java, or an Android, Objective-C
or Swift on iOS.  So, put all
this together.  Combine it with
best in class tooling
for Visual Studio Code or
Android Studio.
Intellij or the framework of
your
choice, and you have Flutter.
For building beautiful
experiences for iOS or Android
from a single codebase.  What
does this mean for you?
Well, as a business, you no
longer need to fund two teams.
You can put all your
resources towards  crafting one
beautiful, native experience
that's available everywhere you
need to be.  But today we're not
just here to talk about Flutter,
we want to show you some
examples of Flutter in action.
And to do that, here's Filip
Hracek.
Over to you,  Filip.
[ Applause ]
FILIP: Thank you, thank you.
So, Tim told you about the four
tenants of Flutter.  Beautiful,
fast, productive and open.  And
it was okay.  Right?  It was a
little bit theoretical.  But
fortunately, I'm here now.
And I'm going to show you how
that translates to practical
stuff.
So, we built an app for this
event.
It's called The History of
Everything.  And I'm going to
give you a little tour of the
app.  And I'm going to show you
how, you know, different things
about Flutter
make things possible or at least
easier.  So, I'll start with the
basics.
The app starts immediately.
Right?  This is because Flutter
compiles ahead
of time to code.
There is nothing to map, no
scripts to parse, it just starts
executing.  Fast.  Right?
Second, this is -- this is an
Android guys and this is an
iPhone.  And as you can see, you
know, the
basic interaction is completely
natural.  If you go to a
different screen, you
know, everything works as you
would expect.  So, these are the
basics.
And this is how Flutter makes
you productive, by letting you
focus on the
custom stuff while doing the,
you know, the basics itself.
I'm going to get rid of one of
the phones just because it's
distracting to have  two.
And I'm just going focus on this
one.  Right?  So, let's take
this a little further.
It's nice to have scrolling but,
you know.  How can we, you know,
tush this up to 11?
So, in this view, we have this
very interactive, very animated
timeline, right?
Where you can go from all the
way from
big bank to today.  And if you
see that red dot, that's all of
human history.  Ah, we'll get
back to that.
But what I'm gonna show you now
is actually so, the scroll
behavior is still completely
natural to the platform.
But we added this really -- I
think it's fun, bouncy effect.
Just to make it more interesting
to, you know, to interact with
the app.  And this is actually a
testament to the openness of
Flutter because we were
able to use Flutter physics,
scroll physics
and add a custom layer on top.
So, Flutter is not just open as
in open source, as in you can
read the
code, of course, but also it
gives you, as a developer,
access to all these classes and
functionality that you can then
build on top of.  But let's take
this a little further, right?
So, it's nice to scroll, but
let's zoom.
So, I'm gonna zoom right past
dinosaurs because it turns out
nobody likes dinosaurs.  Humans.
This is the red dot that we saw
earlier.
And now, as you can see, at any
moment at any scroll position at
any zoom level, we show what
makes the most sense.
And that is possible, again,
because Flutter is fast.  You
can actually -- or we can
actually -- we compute what to
show on every frame.  And this
is basically a requirement
for any very custom UI where you
want to
be able to rebuild things and be
interpretive 60 frames per
second.  Okay.  But let's take
this a little bit further.  So,
you might be thinking, oh, these
are cool.  I like these little
animations.  And you might also
be thinking that
these are actually, you know,
pre-computed.  A GIF or maybe a
video.
But these are actually vector
animations that we're building
on every frame with Flutter.
So, for example, this one.
I can sway the tree above of
Newton.
And I like how, like, the apple
still falls on Newton's head.
Because, you know, life is hard.
And this is possible because,
again, Flutter is fast.
But also because Flutter, at its
deepest level, uses Skia engine.
Skia is  hardware-accelerated,
it
paints directly to the graphics
card and uses all the pixels.
Whatever beautiful design your
designer designs.  Okay.
Whatever artwork your art person
does.  You can do it.
And you can do it again 60
frames per second.  And that's
really cool.  Okay.  Now you
might be thinking, this is all
cool.  But you're showing pixel
3.
That's a very modern phone.  How
about  older phones, right?  And
I'm glad you asked.  Because by
chance I have other
phones with me today.
So, this is -- this is an
Android phone from 2014.
Samsung.
And it's running I think Android
Kit Kat.  And as you can see, it
works just fine.
And here, if I can make it go
away.  And here we have an
iPhone from 2013.  So, five
years ago.  And again, it runs
just fine.  Right.
So, it's not just the modern
phones.  Okay.
If we go to the computer screen.
What magic is this?  Right?  I'm
not going to do any live coding.
But I just wanted you to see
that it's just Flutter code.
All the app itself is all
Flutter.  There is no magic
behind it.  It's all the Flutter
that you all probably -- or at
least many of you know and love.
So, you know, it just compiles
to APK
for Android and IPA for iOS.
And then it, you know, it gets
published to the stores.  This
is actually published like maybe
two hours ago.
This is the App Store and this
is the Play Store.  If we get
back to the phone.  So, yes.
So, we were able in maybe
something like 6,000 lines of
code, we
were able to build a very custom
app in three months with three
people who were busy doing other
stuff as well.
So, that's the productive part,
right?
But there are things that you
won't find in the released
version of the app.  Why?
Because I believe that just
because you can do something
with Flutter, doesn't mean you
should.
For example, can you add 150
little animated hearts to the
timeline that
scroll with it and like, you
know, get bigger and smaller and
all that?  Sure!  Should you do
that?  No.  Maybe yes.  But, no.
Second, that we didn't add to
the
production app, isth last in the
timeline.
And that is obviously Flutter
Live,  right?  Because the
history of everything ends with
Flutter Live.  No, the thing
about it, like, everything that
ever happened since the
history of time has led us to
this moment.  It's true.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
A little bit of philosophy.
Anyway.  What I wanted to show
here is that, you know, Flutter
is all widgets.  It's open.  And
it's composable.
So, if we want to have a video
playing
in our very custom timeline and
being occluded by all these
things, we can.  Because it's
just another widget.  It's
Flutter.  So, sure.
The last thing I want to show
you is basically this but can we
make it -- take it a little
further?
So, that's the blue dot just
above here.  And that is
actually a very substantial
event in the history of
everything.
This is me trying to find this
venue earlier today.  You know?
I got lost in London.  And I was
very  sad.
But I had a device with me
connected to the Internet.
And, you know, there's this
service by
Google that you used if you have
a phone with you and you're
lost.
And as you can see, you know, in
this little animation, wait.
What is this?  Can you see that?
Let me zoom in.  Oh!
Is this an actual Google Map
running inside my Flutter
application?
[ Applause ]
While it's being swayed around.
You know?  Sure!  Because this
is Flutter, right?  So, it's
another widget.  Okay.
So, to summarize, we've seen an
application that I think is
beautiful.
That was built in three months
by three people.
That is fast on a wide range of
devices.  And that, because of
the openness of Flutter, can do
cool things like this.  Thank
you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
TIM: Thanks, Filip.  What do you
think?
[ Applause ]
So, to me, that's a great
example of Flutter, right?  It's
a beautiful experience that does
things that even a traditional
native platform solution might
struggle to do.
So, you've seen a little of what
Flutter can do.
And today, it gives me great
pleasure to announce the general
availability of Flutter 1.0!
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
So, today's release mark
marks a Key milestone for the
product, it's not just for
developers, it's for everyone.
We released Flutter back at
mobile world Congress in
February of this year.  And
looking back over the last nine
months, it's been really quite
humbling
from our point of view to see
how people have adopted and
responded to Flutter.  Since
February, over a quarter of a
million developers have used
Flutter.  Companies large and
small, including
the likes of Alibaba, Groupon,
10 Cent,
Capital One, Filips hew, and, of
course, Flutter are developing
with Flutter.  And we have seen
over 3,000 apps
published on the Play  Store
alone, reaching hundreds of
millions of users.  To show you
some of the momentum that
already exists for Flutter, we
thought it would be fun to put
together a quick
video that thoughs the work that
many of you have done with
Flutter so far.
[ Applause ]
All right.
So, it's time to switch gears a
little.  We're going to take the
next little while to talk
through four core areas of
Flutter.
Starting with designing apps
with Flutter.
Then we're going to talk about
developing Flutter apps.  And
then connecting Flutter to
online services.  And lastly,
we're going to talk about the
process of releasing apps.  So,
let's start with design.
And to start this section off,
I'm
joined by Will who is an
engineer on the design team.
Will, great to see you.
WILL: Thanks, Tim.  I'm so
excited to tell you today why I
believe that Flutter is the
perfect
platform for executing
pixel-perfect designs.  But
first, let's take a step back.
Right now good design is
expensive.  Especially on
mobile.  It  takes extra
engineering resources to
execute.
And what you get is rarely what
you want.
The designer hands us something
detailed and beautiful.
But we push back on what makes
it special.  Branded menu
button.  It's easier to use a
stock icon.  Custom map bar, we
could, but it's complex.  Custom
tabs, we ran out of time.  We
end up compromising on the
details that make our experience
excellent.  And end up shipping
something that's just good
enough.
It has the major features we
need, but none of the finesse.
So, with the best of intentions
we say we'll get to it later.
But let's be honest.  Later
never comes.  The tickets sit in
our backlog and we never delete
them because that would be
admitting defeat.  But what gets
me so excited
about Flutter is that we can
break that cycle.
We can ship the app we really
want.
With detail and polish and
fewer of those painful
compromises.
Flutter's architecture and
designed for building beautiful,
custom UI.  Flutter's main goal
is to make building polished,
custom app interfaces a faster,
more delightful experience for
designers and developers.
Firstly, Flutter is powerful
enough to draw anything
designers dream up.  It's built
on Skia.  The open source
graphics engine used
by Adobe, Chrome and Amazon
Kindle.  We can get
print-quality custom
typography without needing to
dive down to low level
frameworks like core text.
There's easy to access APIs for
character spacing and word
spacing.
Its animation and motion
framework is
more finely  tuneable than
anything I have ever seen on
mobile.  We've looked closely at
what developers need to execute
complex, high fidelity designs
on the  devices of today and put
it at their fingertips instead
of burying
it in obscure, hard-to-learn
frameworks.  And we've used
these APIs to make a
component library expressing
opinionated
and flexible design standards.
Material components for Flutter.
These are reusable widgets
designed by the Material design
team here at Google.  If you
haven't heard, we released a
major expansion of Material,
making the system more flexible
and expressive.
And the Flutter team has done a
great
job implementing the Material
components to our
specifications.  So, we can get
a beautifully-themed experience
out of the box.
On Flutter, Material is
beautiful.  It's a platform
powerful enough to build
anything our designers dream up.
It's also extensible.
We can extend the existing
Material components to support
almost anything.
And often much more easily than
in traditional code.
But maybe most impressively,
Material is fast.  I actually
built these screens on the
subway on my way to work in
about half an hour.  The layout
system in Flutter is just that
good.  I believe Material design
is the most expressive and
flexible cross-platform design
system you could  need.  But
Flutter's powerful enough to
implement any design system.
So, Material components isn't
the only library that comes with
Flutter.  You also get
Cupertino.  A faithful
implementation of Apple's iOS
design language.
Cupertino gives us action
sheets,
alerts, segment controls,
sliders, NAV bars, switches.
Over two dozen widgets that look
like they came right out of UIK.
But 100% open source.  And
coming from traditional iOS,
that's  mind-blowing.  If I have
a question about a text
field, I can go look at its
source code.
And you can't do that with
private APIs.
Cupertino even plays well with
Material components on iOS.  So,
I automatically get iOS-style
controls when I run a Material
app on an iPhone.  But it
doesn't matter if you're using
a design system or a completely
custom UI.  Flutter is faster
than traditional mobile  coding.
In fact,
we've seen teams make up to 3X
gains in velocity using Flutter.
That can  dramatically alter
what your team can accomplish.
And we've already seen some of
you do amazing things with
Flutter.  This is Reflectly.
An award-winning app on iOS and
Android and it's built with
Flutter.  I would like to invite
designer/developer Jacob
Christianson, founder of
Reflectly to join me on stage.
Jacob.
JACOB: Thank you so much, Will.
So, hello, everyone, my name is
Jacob.
I'm a co-founder at Reflectly
and head up UX design as well as
frontend development.  Now,
Reflectly is what we call a
conversation-based journal.
Now, what that means is that
every day users open up the app
and go through a series of
questions which helps them lock
down their day.  However,
instead of a blank screen and
they fill in some text like you
would in a traditional journal,
we prompt them
with very specific UI
interactions such as rating the
day with a smiley face
slider or an icon that
represented how the day went.
This is bundled together into
what we call a story.
The users can then go back in
their journal and reread the
stories to see what they were up
to and how they felt.  And we
can show them how they have
been progressing over time by
giving them aggregated
statistics.  This makes
Reflectly easy to use.  But we
have seen it bring immense value
to our users.  Our users are
becoming
happier over time by using
Reflectly.  Which, of course, is
amazing.   Now, Reflectly is
just around the corner from
hitting that 1 million user mark
globally.
All of whom were able to use
this
amazing app built  entirely in
Flutter.
WILL: That's really great,
Jacob.  A couple questions.  Was
this your first Flutter app?
JACOB: Yes, it was.
WILL: And how many engineers
were working on it?
JACOB: Just me for the frontend.
WILL: How long did it take you?
JACOB: The first line of Flutter
was written in March.  And with
the learning curve, two and a
half months.
WILL: That's crazy.  Wow.  Thank
you, Jacob.  Thank you.  Jacob
Christianson.
[ Applause ]
I really believe we might be
entering a new  age.  One in
which we don't tell designers
that we're going to be getting
to something later or  soon.
But now.
Flutter makes executing
beautiful designs easy.  And
with that, I would like to turn
things back over to Tim.  Tim?
[ Applause ]
TIM: So, you've heard how the
architecture of Flutter makes it
possible for designers and
developers to work together to
create beautiful UI.  And again,
this is where Flutter
stands out as you saw with the
demo in the big history app.
It's the composition of text,
video, graphics and UI controls
whether from Flutter or the
underlying platform applying
animations and transformations
on to a single
hardware-accelerated surface
that makes Flutter such a
powerful platform.  And a
powerful addition to the
toolkits of designers and
developer developers.
But while Flutter bridges the
gap to designers, we think
there's an opportunity to give
creative professionals the same
boost to
productivity that stateful hot
reload gives to developers.
And we have been working with a
company who have been investing
in this space for a little
while.  And they've got some
tools that I think you might be
interested to see.
So, I want to invite  Two
Dimensions on to the stage.
[ Applause ]
GUIDO: I'm a designer.  What I
really like about Flutter is how
easy it makes it for us to
create beautiful applications.
Now, as a designer, I always
have big plans for what I'm
gonna build.
I love coming up with new
interactions, slick animations,
epic lens flares, you name it.
That said, once I've got these
concepts down, I then have to
figure out
how I'm going to actually code
all of this awesome stuff.  And
that's when I think, how cool
would it be if I had a twin that
could code it all for me?
Well, I have good news!
Today we are launching a clone
program.
[ Applause ]
Just kidding.
I am, indeed, lucky to have a
twin.  And he's an engineer.
This is Luigi, by the way.  But
thanks to our new tool and
Flutter, you won't need a
complimentary twin like us.
LUIGI: We are 2Dimensions and we
are here today to talk about a
new product we build called
Flare.  Flare is a vector design
and run-time animation tool that
exports directly to Flutter.
We built Flare to designers like
ourselves and developers can
work in parallel.
GUIDO: If you're a designer, the
biggest advantage to Flare is
that you do get to work
directly on the assets that run
in your final app.  That means
you don't need to design in
one app, animate in another app,
redline
your mockups, write up a
hundred-page guide to basically
help your engineering team redo
all the work that you already
did.  Everything that you design
in Flare is exactly what runs in
Flutter.  Not only does this
open up your entire team to be
able to quickly iterate, but it
also allows you to make great
design a part of your process
from the very beginning right up
until the completion of your
app.
So, we have a demo and we're
going to show you how all this
works.
LUIGI: So, what Guido is going
to pull
up is a Flutter list view,
that's on a refresh animation.
As Guido pulls the list down,
there's a zoom animation with
the movement of the list.  And a
couple idle animations like the
Earth spinning, the stars
twinkling and
the comments that are blended on
top, regardless of where his
finger is or the list view is
placed.  This is all animated in
different layers.  So, this
would all be pretty difficult to
achieve with a video or an image
sequence.  Instead, these are
all animations that I created.
And I'm going to show you a
little bit of what the file
looks like in Flare.  So, this
is our space demo.  And these
are all the animations I created
for this app.
There's this pull animation
which Luigi hooked up to
basically progress as you're
pulling your finger.  And as you
can see, the Earth isn't
actually rotating, the clouds
and continents aren't moving.
There's a separate animation
called idle here, that's where
it's happening.
If I blend the two animations
together, all the stuff is
happening together.   The other
animations are a simple success
state which happens when the
users pull their finger far
enough.  It just lets the user
know, you know, something
happened, success.
And then it goes into this
loading indeterminate state
waiting for the loading to
finish.  That's it.
That's created in Flare and
Luigi hooked it up to work.
LUIGI: It only takes a few lines
of code to get it running in
Flutter.
Once it's done, Guido can keep
iterate
on this design completely by
himself.
GUIDO: That's a good point.  So,
going back to the simulator
here, now that I'm actually
seeing this running here, I kind
of think that the moon spinning
actually looks sort of boring.
I think we could do something a
little more exciting with it.
And that's a good opportunity to
show you guys how easily I can
update that
and iterate on it without taking
up any of Luigi's time.  I'm
loading Flare, in the animation,
grab the moon orbit key frames
and hit delete.  What I actually
want to do is have the moon kind
of move from a side view.  I
want it to move like this.  So,
I'm gonna set a key frame at the
start here for the position.
I'm gonna set the same key frame
at the end.  And then right
about the middle here,
I'm gonna put negative 60 to
inverse  it.  So, now we've got
the movement.  I'm going to add
just some easing to it.  And I
want this to be kind of playful,
so, I'm going for a bit of an
exaggerated curve.  I already
set up the draw curve so that it
switches.  And
you can see that we have our new
orbit here.  And one last thing
to really sell this animation.
And that's to add just a little
bit of scale to make this look
cartoony.
So, I'm going to add two key
frames first for our normal
scale.  And right about here
where the moon is  passing in
front of the Earth, I'm going to
double our X.  And you'll see
that this creates just
a little bit of playfulness.
LUIGI: All right.  I think
that's good enough for now.
Let's see how I get this back
into  Flutter.
GUIDO: I hit export.  Switch
over to our assets and just drag
and drop our new asset over the
old one, hit replace.
And then I switch over to VS
code, do a hot restart because
we need to reload our asset.
And we've got my new moon
animation in  there.
[ Applause ] I was able -- I was
able to
do all that have without taking
up any of Luigi's time.
And I can keep iterating as long
as I want.
LUIGI: It's good at UI
components as well as animation
components as you just saw.
This is an expand application
that Guido built for the
everything app.  This is a
broken heart in the favorites
list when it's empty.
But Flare shines at building
complex animation systems that
are easy to control.  Full
control for bones, constraints
and inverse cinematics.
And you say May have seen this
Amelia Earhart, allows her eyes
and nose and mouth and face to
move without making them
animated individually.  The
animater can key frame one node
or have a developer control it
in Flutter and have all these
constraints work there as well.
And in this other example, Guido
can move the hipbone for this
character and you can see that
her feet and her legs bend and
move in the correct direction as
you would expect, and that's due
to
the inverse  kinematics that we
export.
GUIDO: As you can see, Flare is
between design and development
and you can make great design a
fundamental part of your
process.  I'm really  excited to
announce that
Flare is launching today on
2Dimensions.com and it's free.
[ Applause ]
If you're a developer, you'll be
able to
find a bunch of assets on
2dimensions.com.
And their available for free on
2dimensions.com.  We are excited
that Flutter is going 1 .0
today, and we can't wait to see
how you'll use Flare with it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
TIM: Wow.  Thanks, Luigi,
thanks, Guido.  So, that is
Flare.  Flare bridges the gap
between designers and
developers.
Designers are at last able to
fully participate from beginning
to end in the development of an
app.  Creating interactive
content that can
evolve along with the rest of
the app.  Okay.
So, we've talked about design
with Flutter.
Let's now switch to the
developer.
You know, writing code can often
be a frustrating process.
Particularly when you're working
with a new framework.  And
perhaps one of the best things
about web development is how
immediate it is.  You know, you
can make changes and you can see
them reflected in real-time
without the painful edits,
compile, run,
debug cycle that slows down
traditional development.  With
Flutter, we've taken a lot of
inspiration from that model.
And here to show you how fun it
can be to develop with Flutter
are Emily and Matt.  Hey, you
guys.
[ Applause ]
MATT: So, hopefully so far
you've seen a whole bunch of
really cool and beautiful apps
built in Flutter.  What we want
to do is show you something a
little different.  What it's
actually like to build a Flutter
app.  What the developer
experience is like.
So, we've got a laptop.  We have
a mobile phone.
And what we're gonna do is we're
gonna start to play around with
some code.  Because one of the
things that we feel Flutter
really gives you as a developer
is a really, really nice
development experience.
So, we're gonna mirror our
mobile phone on to our laptop.
And we are going to get -- build
ourselves a -- an app.  And it's
all going to go swimmingly.
Because it's actually gonna be
live.
EMILY: Got an ADB not
responding.
MATT: And we're starting off
really well because our ABD is
not responding.  Yes!
[ Applause ]
I'm going to keep talking about
how wonderful the development
experience is.  It's not
necessarily --
EMILY: The builds --
MATT: The experience.
EMILY: You can tell them what
we're gonna  build.
MATT: Okay.
So, we're going to play around
with clocks.  Because we feel
that clocks are underrated as
apps.  And we're gonna actually
try to make them interesting.
But the real reason we're doing
it is because what we did
initially, as you'll see any
second, honestly, I really,
really promise, is that we put a
very, very basic app together.
And what this app is, is a
countdown app.
And when we click "Go," it's
going to start counting down.
And we didn't put a reset button
in there.  So, this is going to
countdown to zero and that is
going to keep us honest as to
what we're gonna build and we're
gonna see how this goes.  So,
we're up and running, great.
We're gonna take about 30
minutes to --
EMILY: 15.
MATT: We're gonna take 25
minutes.
EMILY: 15.
MATT: We're gonna take 20
minutes.
EMILY: 10.
MATT: We're gonna take 15
minutes to build an app.
EMILY: How about 12?
MATT: Emily rounds down.  We're
going to take 12 minutes.  And
you've already started.  Okay.
Emily, explain roughly how our
base works?
EMILY: So, as Matt mentioned, we
have a  countdown app written in
Flutter.  As you can see, it's
rather boring.
But we were wondering, what if
countdown apps could be fun as
Flutter is fun, and beautiful.
This is not yet beautiful.
Let's take a look at what we
have written here.  So, we've
got a simple clock.  And if you
ever come across a clock in your
lifetime --
MATT: We're not going to explain
clocks.  People get clocks and
we have 11 minutes and 24
seconds left.
EMILY: Okay.
As you will all experience,
clocks tick.
Every second an event -- time is
passing.
And so, what we have here is
we've got
a stream that our program can
subscribe to in every second an
event occurs saying the amount
of  remaining time that is left.
So, we can subscribe to the
stream.
And on our simple clock, we can
build based on that stream.  So,
we have this stream builder.  We
are listening to that countdown
stream.
And then based on each time we
get an update, AKA, a second has
passed, we're going to print
that text.
MATT: So, the moral of the story
here
is, time is inexorbly counting
down and we need to get busy.
Emily and I could not agree on
what we were going to build.  I
wanted to build a retro clock
because I love my '70s ch
EMILY: And I wanted to showcase
features with the mobile phones,
so, we have a mobile app.
Interactive timers are best.
MATT: So, in 10 minutes and 50
seconds, we are going to build
two.  We can combine these into
the app and use the same timers
so we cannot cheat.  Where am I
going to start.  Let's take a
look here.  Let's close that
down.  And I am start here with
basically a blank file.  I have
nothing.  And I'm going to start
with a widget.  Because in
Flutter, everything begins with
a widget.  In the beginning,
there is a widget.
And I'm going to call this retro
clock.
EMILY: And as you can see, this
widget has a build method.  This
is what gets called when you're
drawing the particular widget to
screen which is not yet being
drawn.  And, yeah.
MATT: Okay.
What says '70s chic to you?
EMILY: Orange and brown?
MATT: Orange and brown is one.
But also wood grain.  We're
going to add wood grain in.  I
bet you thought you were going
so see something awesome.
Now you're going to get wood
grain.  I'm going to layer a
stack.
We can layer widgets on top of
each other with a stack.  Start
with the wood grain.
EMILY: This has one widget in
it.  But spoiler alert, there
are more widgets on top.
AUDIENCE: And because we are
going to
see all the clocks, what to use?
EMILY: Wrap in a page view to
swipe between the block clocks
to see all of
them
MATT: Wrap page view, retro
clock first.
EMILY: Bold move.
MATT: And lo and behold.  Did it
disconnect?
EMILY: It did.
MATT: It did disconnect.  This
is going so  well.  This is
awesome.
I knew we should have used the
iOS.
Bear with us while we reconnect
here.  The problem here is that
we're not only counting down,
so, the app restarts.  It
doesn't start at the  same -- or
at a new time or at the
beginning time.
We're persisting this to the
device.  So, it's probably still
clicking down at this moment in
time.  So, we're not going to
get anymore extra time to work
in this.  We're going to be able
to constrain
ourselves even further.
So, with Flutter, even though it
isn't quite obvious to you at
the moment, what you can
actually do is develop really
nicely with the phone plugged
in.
And hot reload over to the
phone, iOS or Android.
And we work well with emulators
and simulators and even do funky
things like.  Did I mess up?
EMILY: You added a few too many
parentheses.
MATT: Did I do that?
EMILY: Yes.
MATT: Why do I have a job?
EMILY: Yeah, creating empty
spaces.
MATT: I used to write lists.
This was easy back then.
EMILY: Okay.
MATT: Keep going now?
EMILY: Yes.
MATT: It's relaunching.  Can I
get back at the keyboard?
EMILY: Go for it.
MATT: I'm going for it.
EMILY: While it's reloading, we
stored time in the preferences.
MATT: Dear me, it's wood grain!
Yes!  Yeah, wood grain,
wonderful.
EMILY: If only we knew what time
it was, Matt.
MATT: If only we knew what time
it was.  Too late.  I'm going to
put back in simple clock because
with simple clock everything is
a widget and we can reuse
widgets.  And lo and behold, we
have an incredibly difficult
time that we can't read.  Let me
style that up a bit.  And we
will put that in  and, okay.
So, we have eight minutes and
we've gotten to wood grain on a
clock.
EMILY: I think you've achieved
Swedish  minimalism.
MATT: I think I have.  So, let
me fix that.  I'm going to put
it in a clock frame widget.  In
my clock frame widget, what I'm
going to use here is I'm going
to use a card.
EMILY: Yeah.  So, a card is just
like a  container.  You can give
it color.  And it has some
elevation, it has some nice edge
-- you can round the edges.
Make it stand out.
MATT: Exactly.  And again, I can
just swap out my widgets as I
build this up.  And there we go.
We have a card which is kind of
boring.  So, let's make it a
little more framing.  So, I can
give it a  shape.  And I can
give it a border.  And this
border.  Border, color.  Some
roundedness.  Okay.
That's looking more clocklike,
right?
EMILY: I thought this was
supposed to be a retro clock and
this is looking pretty darn
digital.
MATT: Okay.  I can do something
about that.  Create another
widget and stack them up.  And
this time I'm going to create a
clock face.  What I'm going to
do now, I'm going to
use and cheat, and use a package
built by one of our community.
EMILY: Someone else in our
community wrote this really cool
package called flip panel.
And Matt wrote some styling
around that and has a variant,
flip digit.  We're using that.
MATT: We have a problem, no
longer using simple clock.  I
don't have a clock anymore.  I
need access to the countdown
stream.
EMILY: Matt is going to access
using an inherited widget to
pull down this stream so we can
listen and receive updates.
MATT: And I'm going to swap out
my
simple clock now with my clock
face.  And whoa.  There we go.
Best clock ever?
[ Applause ]
Wait!  Wait!  There's more.
We're not done  yet.
EMILY: Yeah, but I want to see
how many minutes we have.
MATT: You don't to want see how
many minutes we have left.
EMILY: You're right, I don't.
That's fine.
MATT: Can I close my
parentheses?  No, I can't.  So,
let's -- let's reuse that.  So,
what I'm doing here is I'm
simply
creating a row so I can lay
things out horizontally.  And
I'm going to put in four flip
digits one for each, the tens,
the  seconds, the ones and
whatnot.  And I'm going to save
that.  And there we go.  I think
at this point, this is retro
enough?
EMILY: Yeah, yeah, it's good.
And I'm ready to take over the
keyboard.
MATT: I'm getting kicked off.
Good.
Hopefully you've seen, if you
put in
the parentheses, coding Flutter
is straightforward.  What I've
done is created something by
styling up a bunch of pieces, a
little bit of animation, using a
package.  We're going to get a
little more advanced now because
what Emily wants to build is a
photo clock.
EMILY: Yes.
MATT: What Emily is using here
is using a  stateful widget.  I
was using stateless because I
didn't have any state to follow.
Emily's going to have a little
bit of state to manage later on
and we'll get back to that in a
minute when it becomes obvious.
So, we have in stateful widget
and inside what are we doing
when we run this thing?
EMILY: Yeah.
So, with stateful widgets you
have
this init state method that you
can call when the first time
that a stateful widget is
called.
Hold on, I'm just going to pull
up the clock so we know how
we're doing.
MATT: So you can see here we
have -- we're  using the camera
plugin.  One of the plugins
built by the Flutter team which
gives you full access
to all of the cameras and camera
activities actions that you can
do on both iOS and Android.
What we want to do is take a
photo every minute.  We want to
hurry up because we have four
and a half of them left.
So, we're going to -- Emily has
done funky math to basically say
every time we hit zero on the
seconds, take a picture.  We're
doing the right thing with
permissions.
EMILY: Yeah.  What you saw is I
initialized the camera.  It said
it was asking me for permissions
to use the camera.
MATT: Technically in 7 seconds,
we're going to get a photo
taken.  So, we shall do our
first  selfie.  And by the power
of Flutter, there was a photo
taken.  Isn't that wonderful?
We have our word for it.  Let's
show something actually.
EMILY: I'm going to put this in
a column so we can put the clock
and then the image that we took
just below it.  And then I wrote
a widget ahead of
time called Filmstrip that --
so, you remember we were talking
about streams for the time.  We
also set up a stream that is
listening to the file  system.
So, when we take a photo, we are
writing to that file system and
we have a listener.
And then when that is updated,
we -- we tell Flutter that we
need to rebuild.  So, I'm going
to add that in.
MATT: We're going add this in, a
column here, and I used a row.
And we have a selfie!  This is
great.
EMILY: Another picture coming
up.
MATT: I'm going to get a selfie.
This is going to be great.
Three, two, one and photo.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
We're going to make this so we
can scroll back to the other
photo, right?
EMILY: Yes.  Because I like the
first one better.  So, let us
switch this out.  Right now
we're showing the first of the
film images.
So, instead, we're going to use
a list view.
And we're gonna scroll
horizontally
through all of the photo paths.
MATT: So, we have managed to
squeeze in stacks, columns, rows
and list views almost by
accident.  But we got them all
in.  So, now we can scroll
through these photos and this is
great.  And we're starting to
get somewhere.  But we're not
quite done yet, are we?
EMILY: No, I'm going to add some
styling.
MATT: Even though I ate up all
your
time, you seem to be making some
up and we have 2 minutes and 10
second left.
EMILY: Yes.
First I'm going to add some
images to make it look a little
more like a camera.  Oh.
I'm glad that Dash could visit.
MATT: There we go.
EMILY: Maybe visited the
haberdashery.
And I'm going to set styling to
make this fill in.  I've got a
nice font.
MATT: So, we're going to style
up the time and make it not look
super-modern.  We're going to go
art deco.  This is going to be
fairly eclectic.  We have the
time ticking down.  We have some
styling around it.  What else do
we need to do?  Oh, we're gone
in put in a -- we have two
cameras on this phone, not one.
And we can access both of them.
So, what we can do here is we
can pop in a button.
And that's gonna let us --
EMILY: Switch the direction of
the camera.
MATT: Switch the direction of
EMILY: So, it's a pretty easy
button.  You can see here when
the button gets pressed, we are
going to switch the direction of
the camera.  And this is where
the statefulness of the widget
comes into place.  We are
setting the state.  And here,
I'll show you.  So, you see
that?
If you tap the button, you can
see the text will change.  And
so, it's changing states.
Now, the alignment is a little
wonky.  I'm going to fix that.
Make it interested.  Okay.
There's one more thing.
MATT: We have 35 second.  What
are we going to do?
EMILY: So, there's a really cool
other  third-party plugin that
has this kind of explosion
animation.  And so, I --
MATT: We're going to make
ourselves self-destruct in 22
seconds.
EMILY: Yes.
MATT: Not that we made it
self-destruct  already, at least
twice.
EMILY: Yes.
MATT: We're gonna make it?
EMILY: We're gonna make it.
MATT: You've got 10 seconds.
EMILY: We are gonna make it.
MATT: House lights, please.
Everybody raise your arms.
Three, two, one, say cheese!
Oh, look at that.  There we go.
[ Applause ]
fireworks!
We've subjected you to enough
live coding so we'll stop it
there.  Thank you very much.
EMILY: And enough adrenaline.
Yeah.
Rest easy now.
TIM: I have so much respect for
those guys.  To pull that off in
that length of time is just
amazing.  Whoof!  Over the last
couple of months we
spent a lot of time talking with
company building with Flutter
and learning how they're using
it.  And in particular towards
1.0, we were interested to see
what things did we need to
continue to invest in and so,
there's a bunch of things that
we have been sort of working on
and adding over the last couple
of months.  Particularly in the
runup to Flutter 1.0.
So, firstly, developers told us
as Will mentioned, they wanted
to see support or better
supports for building
apps that fully model the iOS
design guidelines.
So, we've added lots more
widgets and classes that make it
possible to build
those  pixel-perfect experiences
for iPhone.  Secondly, as Filip
showed, developers wanted to be
able to integrate other platform
content into the Flutter apps.
We have done the heavy lifting
work to
bring this directly into the
Flutter come positive iter.
And we have previews of a Google
Maps plugin and a web browser
plugin.  And we heard loud and
clear that developers wanted to
be able to add Flutter to
existing apps, rather than just
creating new apps with Flutter.
It's actually been possible for
a while.  But we've done a lot
of work over the last couple of
months to improve the tooling,
the build process, the
debuggability of this scenario.
And we'll continue to invest in
this space over the next couple
of months.  And, of course,
that's not all that's in Flutter
1.0.  We fixed a bunch of bugs.
We've continued to refine and
polish it.  One feature I'm
particularly proud of is adding
localization of the UI
content to 50 languages from
Arabic to
Vietnamese, Marati to
Swiss-German.  Even English.
Many of these have come to
community contributions.  So,
thank you if you have been
involved in that process also.
Lastly, Flutter 1.0 includes
Dart 2.1.
Which adds additional compile
time
checking, increased performance
and reduced code size.
A recent study of GitHub pull
requests shows that Dart is one
of the fastest-growing
languages.  And that's also
backed up by the
latest addition of the Tyobi
index.
And as you'll see later, Dart
gives Flutter unique advantages
because of its versability as a
platform.  Okay.  So, we've done
design.  We've done develop.
We're now going to move on to
talk about another part of the
development process.
Connecting to external service
services.  As I mentioned
earlier, one of the reasons why
Flutter is so productive for
mobile development is the
package ecosystem.  We
deliberately made the core of
Flutter as small as possible.
And we used the plugin model
ourselves to ship new features
out.
We already have over 1,000
Flutter
plugins covering everything from
video
playback to Facebook
authentication, SQLLite to
GraphQL.  These packages are
fully open source.  Many of them
are contributed by the
community.  And
they make it easy to add support
for new services.
For mobile developers, Firebase
provides an array of key app
services
such as analytics, databases,
sign-in,
push notifications, and crash
reporting.  Most of them are
already supported
with first-party Flutter
integrations.  And Flutter 1 .0
increases this support further.
To show how these plugins come
together to make Flutter apps
even more
connected, please welcome
Maurice Parrish to the stage.
Maurice, great to see you.
MAURICE: Thank you, Tim.  All
right.  Get  logged in here.
[ Applause ]
Make sure everything's
connected.
It looks like we're going to
have to reconnect this.
All right.  Here we go.
Perfect.  Hey, everyone.
My name summaries and I'm the
engineer that works on Flutter's
plugins.  I would like to show
you something cool that we have
been adding to Flutter.
As you can see here, we have an
avatar of me.  And just like the
timeline app, the design and
animation have been provided
using Flare.  Right now the
avatar is just standing idle.
That's kind of  boring.  So,
what we can actually do is we
can move these sliders.
We can have his face animation
move and have some funny
expressions as well.  We can
even give him a big smile.  But
instead of using sliders, what
if
we could have this facial
expression match mine
automatically using the power of
machine learning?  So, let's
look at the code.  So, to
achieve this, we're gonna need
two plugins.  We're gonna need
the camera plugin and
the ML Lkit plugin.  Since this
is
preconfigured for the cam rat ML
Kit, we're going to dive
straight into the code.  What we
need to do is create a class
that will facilitate taking
images from the camera and
passing it to the face detector.
So, I've already gone ahead and
created a class called face
expression reader that does just
that.  This class has three main
components.  It has the camera
controller which controls access
to the camera.  Then we have the
face detector which
runs ML models on images to
detect faces.
The last part is we have the
init method which sets
everything up.  So, what we're
going to do is we're
going to implement the init
method.  What I love about
Flutter is how easy it is to get
started with the camera.
There's two lines.   The first
one is the constructer, showing
we want access to the front
camera.  The second one is we
show we want low resolution
images.  And the second line is
we just initialize the camera.
That's all that we need.  The
next step is initialize the
detector.
And just like the camera, it's
just as easy to set up.  All we
do is get an instance of face
detector from Firebase vision.
However, the default face
detector only looks at images,
but we want to set
it to read facial expressions.
There we go.  Reformat.
The options we're going to set
so it can read facial
expressions.  Enable
classification and have the
detector run in accurate mode.
Last but not least, continuously
string bytes from the camera to
the detector.  And I've already
gone ahead and created a helper
method to do just that.  So, in
this method all we do is pass
the camera into the detector we
just initialized.
But also pass a method that
updates the face expressions
reader every time question get a
new result face from an image.
So, we can actually take a quick
look at this helper method.
It's actually fairly short.  All
we really did is we called this
upcoming method called start
byte stream on the camera.
Every time we get an image, we
take this image.  We pass
it to our detector.  And then
after we get the results for
our detector, we update our face
expression reader.
So, now that we've set all that
up, let's go ahead and go to our
main.dart.  We want to go down
to sour state class.  So, I've
already gone ahead and  created
an instance of the face
expression reader of the class
we just implemented and I called
it  reader.
So, the very last thing we need
to do to get this working is add
a listener to the reader.  And
here we go.
Now with this listener, the face
expression reader will update
our avatar every time it gets a
new face.
So, we're gonna go ahead and run
hot restart.
And the reason we're going to
run hot restart instead of hot
reload is because since we
changed our init state method,
we want to rebuild the entire
state of our class.  Let's see.
I think it's already set up.
There we go.
[ Applause ]
So, not only can it just tell if
I'm smiling or not, we can
actually add a little bit more.
So, we're going to go ahead and
run another hot restart.  What
we did is that we have the --
we're going to update the eyes
and we're going to update the
tilting of the head.
So, if I hold this up to my face
again, close my eyes, tilt
right.  And left.
[ Applause ]
It updates in real-time.  All
right.  So, now that you've seen
how easy it
is to use ML Kit,  hopefully
you'll consider using it in your
app as well.  Thanks, everyone.
[ Applause ]
TIM: Thanks, Maurice!  So, as
Flutter is now at the point it's
starting to gain critical
momentum.
we're starting to see other
companies add direct support.
As an example, today we're
announcing a new partnership
that we think will
open Flutter to a new class of
applications.  Mobile phones are
increasingly being used for
payments.  Both for digital and
physical goods.  Square are one
of the pioneers of payment
services for retailers and
consumers.
And I'm delighted to
introduce Ella Polo to the stage
to
tell us how you are using
Flutter.
ELLA: Thank you, Tim.  At
Square, we believe the economy
is better when everyone has
access.  No one should be left
out because the cost is too high
or the technology too complex.
We started with a little white
reader that let millions of
merchants participate in the
economy by makes it easy to take
credit card payments with your
smartphone.
Since then, we've worked hard to
create an ecosystem of products
that empowers customers and our
developer platform is a key
part.  Our multi-channel payment
includes APIs and SDKs that let
developers integrate payments
into the apps they build.
Square takes care of the
complexity of payments.
In-person,  in-app and online so
a developers can just focus on
building great apps.  Now, we
have been following Flutter
since the beta and we're
impressed by
how it enables developers to
quickly
create beautiful  cross-platform
apps.
Today we have two new plugins.
The Flutter plugin for the
reader SDK and the in-app
payments SDK.
The reader S DK allows merchants
-- and
the in-app payments SDK lets
them build consumer apps that
take payments directly from
buyers.
To see this in action, let's
meet Collins Family Orchards.
They're a small business that
runs on Square.  They're a
fourth generation family
farm growing a variety of
organic fruits in eastern
Washington state.  Selling at
farmers markets in the Seattle
area.  And they use a phone and
a Square reader to take
payments.  Now, the Collins
family was happy running on
Square.  But they wanted to
build an app to accommodate the
specific needs of their growing
business.  So, let's take a look
at an app built specifically for
the Collins family using Flutter
and the Flutter for Square
reader SDK reader plugin.
This app helps them take
payments at
the farmers markets and has
quick actions built in.  Can we
see the app?  It's on the right.
It's branded for Collins Family
Orchards and I'm going to sign
in.  And then choose the
location that I'm selling
at.  Say today I'm although a
farmers
market in  Bellview.  Great.
And enter the amount to charge.
The charge button is disabled.
So, let's look at the code
really quick.  This is the on
checkout function and
this uses the plugin for SDK
Square reader for the check out
flow.
It looks at parameters and
determines the payment flow.
The amount of the transaction,
but
whether we want to collect tips
or show a receipt screen.  And
once we start the checkout flow
you'll notice that there's no
configuration for the reader
here.  And that's because once
we're in the
transaction, Square takes care
of talking to the hardware.
This is really only the
configuration you need.
And nothing is calling this
checkout function.
For the live coding demo, we're
going
to do the hot reload and check
it to call.  And click start to
start the transaction.  Great.
You're seeing the Square
checkout flow.  If I can find my
card.  We can see the reader?
Yes.
And I'll insert my card to take
the
payment.  Great.  And the
payment was accepted.  Now, when
we look at the list of
transactions for this location,
we can see the payment they just
took right there.
[ Applause ]
As you can see, it's really easy
to add  payments into your
Flutter app with Square.  The
Flutter plugin for the Square
SDK is available  today, and the
Flutter plugin for the in-app
payments is available for early
access.
And you can read more about
both.  And we're happy to be
partnering with Google on this
and to see what we can do with
Flutter in the future.  Thank
you.
[ Applause ]
TIM: Thank you, Ella.  And thank
you, Square.  So, the last part
of the app life cycle we're
going to talk about is release.
As you have been hearing
throughout the presentation, our
goal is to make Flutter the most
productive way to build
beautiful, fast experiences for
both iOS
and Android from a single
codebase.  But when it comes to
continuous integration,
continuous deployment, sometimes
feels that we're still a little
bit stuck in the olden  days.
It's just a little bit too hard
sometimes to configure build and
test tooling.  Particularly if
you're trying to target both iOS
and Android.
Lots of knobs and switches and
manual configuration.  Sometimes
feels like being a phone
operator in the 1950s.
If only there was a build system
that understood Flutter.
Well, turns out there's a
company who has been doing that.
Let me introduce Nevercode.
TRIIN:  I'm so excited to be
here and celebrate in Flutter
Live event with people here and
online.  So, hey, people online!
So, at Nevercode we have been
building our continuous
integration and delivery product
for mobile developers and
companies such as Toyota,
Walmart to name a few.
And we have seen them struggle
with setting up the whole
development process for iOS and
Android separately.
So, when we heard what Flutter
does and how it actually changes
the way how mobile apps are
developed, we were convinced
that the whole CIDC experience
needs to be reengineered.
So, I'm  proudly presenting you
our
brand new product:   Codemagic.
[ Applause ]
So, I'm going to show you how it
works.  And I'm going to show
you easy it is to set up the
whole pipeline to build your
Flutter apps on codemagic.
So, actually the beauty starts
already when you join with a
GitHub account.
Because, you see, it
automatically understands your
Flutter apps and  pulls them to
codemagic.  And it's very easy.
You just kick off the first
build.  And voila.  It starts.
You see the whole process here
on one screen.  So, of course,
you know, normally you would
have web hooks that trigger the
build from GitHub after each
commit.  But the underlying
thought when we were building
this product was that it needs
to be seamless, it needs to be
intuitive, so that even a person
with no
prior CI/CD experience can start
very, very quickly.
So, just to demonstrate to you
some of the, you know, the UI
that we have in mind.  For
example, I'm taking this -- oh,
there's a huge lot -- okay.
Here's a failed build.  Because
you want to know why things are
failing
sometimes.
So, here you see that the build
failed because it failed to
install dependencies.  And here
you get more information like
what happened to make the next
decisions.
And then, if you want to
configure your app more on
codemagic because, you
know, it's not just for
hobbyists or freelancers.
It's also for hardcore
developers who maybe want to
experience a more
sophisticateed product.  So, you
just go to the app settings here
you see, you know?
Seems like just small steps, but
actually you can customize here
a lot.  For example, I have
chosen that I only want to build
the Android app.  And, for
example, in publishing you can
publish automatically to Google
Play
or Appear Store and out of the
box integration with iOS and
Android.
So, as I'm on Slack very often,
of course, I want my
notification to end up in Slack
channel.  So, I have chosen here
that I want to know when the
build starts when it fails.  Or
when the artifacts are
published.  So,
let's go see how far are we
building this app currently?
Okay.  So, you see that it's
currently building the Android
app.  And already you can open
up the steps to see everything
what's going on here.
So, it  gives you a lot of
flexibility.  And another thing
that I also wanted
to mention that I kind of -- if
I go
here to app settings -- is that
you can also actually look at
the workflows according to the
user groups.  Maybe you want to
have them to different people.
To testers, beta testers, some
other team in your company.
Okay.
It shows that the build was
successful.  So, I'm just going
to the build.  And here!
Everything is green.  It's a
really nice green.
So, I promised that they should
be on Slack.  So, let's go check
out my Slack channel.  And they
are!  Great!  The artifacts are
actually here.
[ Applause ]
So, you know, I'm convinced that
Flutter
plus codemagic is the fastest
road to get your apps to the
hands of your end users.  So I
invite everyone to join and sign
up at codemagic.io.  It's free.
It's live now.  You can just go
crazy.  And then you can also
join our Slack channel where all
the other Flutter fans are and
just share your experience,
learn from others.  So, I think
it will be awesome.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]
TIM: Thank you so much.  We're
so excited that codemagic is
working with us here and we hope
you'll all try it out with your
own Flutter projects.   Okay.
We've covered the four things.
We're nearing the end of the
presentation.  Which is a
perfect time to look a little
beyond Flutter 1.0.  Hopefully
you've now seen how Flutter
is beautiful, fast, productive
and open.  You've seen how
designers and developers can
collaborate to build native
mobile apps.
You've seen how the ecosystem
extends Flutter with plugins
from companies like Square.
And you've seen tools like
2Dimension's Flare that amplify
the power of Flutter.  But we're
not quite done.
Flutter was not conceived as an
SDK for iOS and Android.  Our
vision for Flutter is to be a
portable UI toolkit that can go
wherever
you need to paint pixels.  The
Flutter engine is inherently
cross-platform and it can be
embedded in all kinds of
hardware.  Just last week, we
shared an example
of porting Flutter to run on
Raspberry Pi.
Running directly on the broad
com
hardware rather than an
intermediary layer like Linux or
X11.  We believe Flutter is a
useful building block for these
kinds of embedded scenarios.
And perhaps in the future, we'll
see Flutter powering things like
automotive
displays or other IoT kinds of
devices.  Another very practical
example of how we are already
going beyond mobile is Flutter
desktop embedding.
This is an open source project
that enables Flutter apps to run
on Mac, Linux and Windows.  We
have been working on Flutter
desktop embedding in the open
for a few months now.  And we're
pretty happy with how it's
coming on together.  This lets
you do things like take your
basic starter application that
you get when you create a
Flutter project and run it on a
Mac.  So, like here's the --
here's the
usual app here and you can
imagine, you know, you can plus
and see how the number
increments.  And in fact, when
we were putting this
presentation together, we were
thinking,
how could we make our slides as
beautiful as possible?
So, we built the entire
presentation in Flutter.
[ Applause ]
Everything you've seen so far
has been run on the Mac
implementation of Flutter.  The
app has been built by a company
called Very Good
ventures, a New York-based
studio who focus on developing
beautiful Flutter experiences.
We plan to open source this
software soon.
But that's not all.
There's one other place we would
like to go with Flutter that
really demonstrates the ground
breaking potential of this
technology.  And you know,
before I get there, I
have to take a moment --
[ Laughter ]
To talk about Dart.  Because as
well as being a really
well-designed language, it's a
versatile platform for Flutter.
Dart doesn't just compile to
native
ARM code, but also compiles to
tight, production-ready
JavaScript code.
So, I want to give you an early
glimpse of something we're
working on in the labs.
To be clear, this is a
technology preview.
We're not shipping any code
today.  We're calling this
Hummingbird.
And it's a port of Flutter that
runs
on the modern, standards-based
web.
[ Applause ]
I'm going to show you a little
demo of Hummingbird now.  Here's
a simple mobile app that we have
been running on an Android
tablet.
It's an implementation of the
15-tile sliding puzzle that I
suspect we all know pretty well.
You know, I can move tiles
around, and I can auto-play it.
We've done the usual Flutter
things.  We've added a little
bit of styling to it to make it
look beautiful and so on and so
forth.
But I'm gonna open Chrome.  And
browse to this page.
And everything you're seeing
here is Flutter running on the
desktop web browser.
Everything you're seeing here.
[ Applause ]
everything you're seeing here is
standards-based content, HTML,
DOM, Canvas, JavaScript.
There's no black box here
anymore than any other web
content.  Importantly, it's the
same Flutter
code running in this browser as
on the  phone.  We haven't had
to change the code to get it to
run here.  We've still got some
optimization work to do, but you
can see that we're
getting 60 frames per second for
this scenario across the current
generation of devices.  And
because this is the web, I can
even turn it into a PWA if I
want to.  Thanks to the great
work from the Chrome team.  So,
that's  Hummingbird.  What do
you think?
[ Applause ]
Again, this is early days for
this  experimental product.  Our
hummingbird, you might say, is
still learning to fly.  In the
meantime, we're publishing right
now a blog article that
describes
more of the technical details
behind Hummingbird.  And we'll
have much more to share at
next year's Google I/O
conference.
So, portable, high-quality UI
has been
the Holy Grail for frontend
developers for decades.  And
over the course of the last hour
or so, I hope you have seen why
we think Flutter has the
potential to transform how all
manner of UIs are built.  This
is not just about iOS and
Android.  This is about building
beautiful user
experiences on any platform.
We're excited about our mission.
And we hope you are too.
So, to close, I want to
introduce you
to someone whose played a
pivotal role in the Flutter
project.
Eric Seidel is one of the
cofounders of the Flutter
project and he's going to end
this presentation with a few
final thoughts.  Eric,
thank you so much.
ERIC:  Thank you, Tim.
[ Applause ]
A couple of my colleagues and I
started this project at Google
over four years ago.  We just
wanted to make development
better.  We wanted to make user
experiences better.  And these
are themes that many of us had
worked on for years as part of
the Chrome project.  But we felt
that within the
constraints of the web, we
couldn't get there fast enough.
So, we started experiments to
see if we could make something
radically better
for both users and all the teams
that develop for them.  Those
experiments became Flutter.
So, how we got here was a bit
interesting.  It took a little
while.  But we felt a radical
approach was required.
If we were gonna break from
existing systems and build a
whole new way to develop, we
knew that was gonna take a long
time.
But we saw this as an important
long-term investment.
Not just for my team, but also
for Google.
So, as we were starting, we
talked to lots of developers.
We sat down and made many, many
lists of problems that we heard
and
wanted to solve.  I think it's
worth looking back at
least the four big areas that we
set out to solve.
And you've heard some about
these today.  So, the first was
that we wanted to
make it easy to build beautiful
things.  And because, again,
this was a
long-term bet, Flutter had to
make it easy not just to make
the most beautiful things
available today, but also had to
be flexible enough and powerful
enough to build the most
beautiful things being designed
for tomorrow.
The second was that we wanted to
make
it easy to produce consistent,
reliable performance.
We saw developers struggle with
this consistently on other
platforms.  And we wanted to
make it easy to
deliver a really smooth
experience at 60 frames a
second, 120 frames a second, 240
frames a second.
Whatever the underlying device
could do.
Third, we really wanted to
improve the developer
experience.  Developer
productivity has, you know,
again if we were making a
long-term bet, developer
long-term productivity had to
be at least as good as the best
available that day.  And so far,
honestly, we've far exceeded my
expectations with now
sub-second state stateful hot
reload.  And fourth, we needed
to build a thing that could go
wherever Google needed it to go.
It had to be open.  It had to be
extensible.
It had to be flexible to go to
all the places and all the
devices.  Running all the
hardware, the software.  All the
crazy things that Google was
building then and is building
now.
We spent many, many months
working
with a few brave early
customers.  And many times in
response to customer
needs, we rewrote large swaths
of the system.
But we always kept our eyes on
these long-term goals.
In the end, it was a lot of
effort.  Still is a lot of
effort.  But I think the results
speak for themselves.  The many
apps that we've shipped, or that
we've seen shipped, rather.  The
success stories we've heard.
Continue to tell me that we
focused on the right areas and
are getting
good results.  Which brings us
all to today.
So, this, today, our
announcement of 1.
0 is obviously a major milestone
for the project and for the
community and for
the many teams who have worked
for years to get us here.  You
saw today how Flutter is already
enabling developers all over the
world to deliver beautiful apps
to hundreds of millions of
people throughout the globe.
But this is also just the
beginning.
Flutter is Google's portable UI
toolkit.  It is highly portable
and already works on many form
factors beyond phones.  You saw
it used today on desktops for
our slides.  You may have seen
some of the many articles
floating around the Internet of
people taking Flutter and
running it on gigantic things or
little tiny things.
And you even saw today some of
our experiments of running
Flutter on the web.  So, if I
look forward a few years, I
see Flutter running in a ton
more places.  So, finally, and
really the whole
reason why I'm up here, is to
say a big thank you.
[ Applause ]
I want to say personally thank
you to so many for working with
us for so long to get here.
Particularly those who tried
Flutter.  Some of you bet on
Flutter very early
on before it even was  called
Flutter.  I also want to say,
thank you for all the hundreds
of suggestions and bug reports
that this community receives
every month from those
listening.  And finally, of
course, thank you to those
tuning in.  Whether via one of
our -- I think it's over 150
now?
Viewing parties around the
globe.
Via Tweeter, via the livestream.
And, of course, to all of you
here in person.  So, thank you
for taking time out of your day
to celebrate with  us.  And
fittingly, we're gonna close
today's presentation not with
us.  But with you.  Flutter has
always been and always will be a
community effort.  Built
together in the open.  No one
company or one team can reach
all of the places we want
Flutter to go.  So, we close
with our hats off to that
community.  The stories like
we're
about to show you give us the
motivation to continue each day
in this mission.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> I'm a software engineer, born
in Bulgaria.
>> A developer based in Berlin.
>> I'm a Flutter developer.
>> I am a web developer.
>> I'm an Android engineer from
China.
>> I'm from Chicago, Illinois.
>> From Lima, Peru.
>> I'm in Denver, Colorado.
>> Flutter has changed the way I
develop really because of the
fact that I've never really
developed with a bird by my side
all the time.: Flutter changed a
lot of things in our lives.
First of all, it changed the way
that we code.
>> I fell in love with Flutter
from the
very first time I saw Emily live
coding the meme chat app on
Google I/O.
>> And build an app in a single
day.
>> Our company currently works
on five Flutter projects.
>> With Flutter I don't have to
go online and check the docs
anymore.  The way it's
structured makes it easy to jump
into the definition underneath
things.
>> I switched to Flutter from
JavaScript and PHP having
strictly typed code, it's a game
changer.
>> My favorite fact about
Flutter, it doesn't limit your
imagination.
>> I love with Flutter you can
edit the UI code and
simultaneously preview the
changes both on Android and iOS.
>> The UI page developed by
Flutter is very smooth.
Especially on low-end machines.
>> Flutter helps me.
>> This year we decided to make
an app from Flutter.
>> We're using Flutter to
rebuild our native mobile apps.
Three code bases down to two.
>> With Flutter, it's been easy
to bring my ideas to life.
>> One thing I didn't have
experience with, mobile app
development.  Now is as good a
time as any.  I'm building my
own mobile app and I'm doing it
with Flutter.
>> I've open sourced three
Flutter applications on GitHub.
>> These animations are entirely
by Flutter.
>> I like widgets and I like how
it allows me to build apps
quickly.
>> You can quickly turn your
ideas into real applications.
>> I really like the Firebase
integration because I usually
use
Firebase for my projects and
it's
super-easy to get started with
Flutter.
>> I really, really enjoy the
community  engagement on Twitter
as well as on GitHub.
>> That took us almost 16 months
to create an iOS app has taken
less than four months in
Flutter.
>> One of my favorite things
about the Flutter community is
you can find examples about
everything.
>> My favorite part about
Flutter is that it makes me much
more productive.
>> The thing that excites me
most about Flutter and the
Flutter community has to be the
support from the development
team and from the community of
developers.
>> The amazing productivity it
enables.  In months what took
years.
>> And I'm part of the developer
community.
>> With Flutter, I spend less
time compiling and more time
styling.
>> That is my Flutter
development story.
>> That's my Flutter story.
>> And this is my Flutter story.
>> Flutter!
Andrew:  Hey, everybody, I'm
Andrew.
ask Flutter post show.  Thank
you for that introduction and
thank you for being here with us
tonight.  It's true that
Google's putting a lot of effort
into the developments that you
have just heard about, Flutter
is an open source project and
created and supported by an
entire community of SDK
developers, YouTube creators and
more.  And by choosing to join
us tonight, you're now part of
that community.  And we want to
hear your voice.  So, for the
next hour or so, we're answering
your questions live right here.
You can post them in the YouTube
livestream comments or Tweet
using the ask Flutter hashtag
and we'll get to as many as we
can.  You're working the
screens.  You have questions?
>> Yes, a ton of questions.
We're getting about 2 per
second.  Down from the high of
about 7 per second.
>> Okay.
>> We're getting a lot of
Tweets.
>> Cool.
We also have a few drop-in
guests lined up from the Flutter
engineering team and coming to
you from the crowd at Flutter
Live.
If you ask a question I can't
handle, we'll find someone who
can and get them up here and
answer them together.  Ready to
go?
>> Start with an obvious one.
We have been  getting a lot of
questions.  Even before the
keynote we were getting so many
people asking us when are Maps
going to be available on
Flutter?
>> Okay.
>> Now we already have the
answer to that question.
But go into it a little bit
deeper.  Can you give us a demo
how Maps are working on Flutter?
>> Full disclosure. We figured
this was definitely coming.
I've got some stuff on my
laptop.  Real quick, let's take
a look at the code.  One of the
nice things, Flutter is
completely open source.
The SDK, the tools, the language
is open source.  And the plugins
are too.  Let's go to our
plugins repo.  So, this is
Flutter/plugins.  Got it up on
my laptop.
And if you go in here, see a
bunch of the packages that the
team is maintaining and building
out.  Battery, camera,
connectivity and things.
And way down here we have Google
Maps for Flutter.  And so, if
you're ever curious about this
codebase, what can maps do right
now?  Where is it going?  This
is a great place to go check
out.
So, we have the directly, the
imports.  This has the Google
Map widget.  This is Flutter,
everything's a widget.  It has
the Map controller and other
things.  And the Android and iOS
sort of bridge
that goes from Dart into the
Google Maps SDKs for Android and
iOS.  And let's see what code
I've got here.
So, here we have our DevRel
sample for Maps.
This was done by our talented
Kenzie up at our Portland
office, you know well.
And this is up in the
Flutter/samples repo.
That's what DevRel uses for
samples.  All this code you can
get right now.  And let's take a
look at this app.
This is using the Google Map
widget.  And it does the things
you expect a Google Map to do.
You can pan around, zoom in,
places she's added to the map
and a couple sets.  And you can
see if I switch between
them, the map automatically
zooms out just like you would
expect.
I can go in and switch terrain
types.
Street view to satellite.
Topographic if you want to know
where the mountains are.  And
turn it off.  And street view.
And I'm clicking on the buttons
on the
map that you wouldn't normally
see on the Google Map.  They're
Flutter widgets.  She added on
top using a stack.
>> So, the Map widget, just a
widget like any other widget.
>> It's just a widget, doing
things under the hood, but still
just a widget.
In the demo that Filip did,
threw it into a transform.  His
Map was tilted like this.  You
can play with them just like
that.  Speaking of playing with
it, let's ask a little bit.
>> I wanted to ask, how hard is
it to add Maps to your app?
>> A good way to answer that we
would be just to blow away this
entire app.
>> Okay. Let's kill it.
>> This is home. Let's -- I'm
going to replace everything in
the app with just a Google Map.
Let try that.  Here is the
Google Map widget.  And the map,
constructer takes a single
parameter which is on map
created.  And this is a
callback.
So interact with the map, you
use the Google Map controller.
The controller pattern you may
have seen elsewhere in Flutter.
The text fields and some of the
inputs.  This is how you
interact with it, you know,
change its behavior.  So, it has
a little callback that will give
you the controller.  And so, I'm
just going to make a spot to
hold it.
Go up here, make a little Google
Map controller.  Just like that.
And I'll call it map controller.
And I'm gonna sign that down
here.
So, all right.  So, I've got any
widget in place.  I've got the
controller callback.
Let's do a little hot reload.
And there we go.
The entire app now is just a
map.  I can zoom in, I can click
and zoom, I can still pan around
and things like that.  And
all right.  So, let's do
something with this.  We got the
map, we got the controller.
You said before, you could add
buttons over the Flutter map
widget.
Okay.
Let's add a button and we can do
something.
Why won't it let me click the
button?  I'll wrap this in.  Go
with a stack.  Put this in the
stack.  And, of course, stacks
have children, rather than a
single child.  So, we add that.
That's gonna be a list.  Come
down here.
The magic of autoformatting.
And let's put a button.  I'll
put this in the lower left-hand
corner just so we know where it
is.
So, use the positions.  And here
we go.  So, bottom, I'll give it
a little padding.
That's not how you spell bottom.
And left.  A little padding
there.  And child.
I'll give this a raised button.
And so, our button will need
some text.  Let's see.  Let's
move the camera when the button
gets hit, how about that?  There
we go.  And give it an on
pressed.  Every button needs an
on pressed callback that's going
to be used.
And just for fun, let's give it
a color.  Is there a light green
material spec?  There is a light
green.  Awesome.  Okay.  Let's
hot reload again.  Still got
our map.  And let's -- we got a
button now.  Let's move the
camera when we get this clicked.
So, we have the controller.
Updates.
Animated camera.
Let's do ananimative.  And
that's going to take a camera
update.
And we'll do -- let's do Latin
and long here.
Do you know latitudes and long
jiggy attitudes?
-how about London?
You know that?
>> 55.0.
Let's
say Greenwich, but that's close
by.
You want to zoom in a little bit
too?
Yeah.  Let's zoom in a little.
Oh.
I twist it -- let's go ahead and
save this.  Hot reloading again.
And click the camera.  And there
we go.  Now we're interacting
with this map.  In about five
minutes, dropped a Google map in
here, got the controller, and
used it to animate a change to
the map.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Not only Maps now, full Google
Maps, they're really Flutter
widgets and really easy to add
and manipulate.
You can compose with these.
They're just like any other
widgets, you can put them in
here, move them around, do what
you need to do.
That's great.
Like I said, if you have
questions on this, check out the
source code itself
and if you run into any issues
or want features, file an issue
request.
Okay.
That's Maps.  What else?
Well, I've got a couple of
questions.  Here is a question
from India.  We got a lot of
questions from India.  Probably
I think they win the award for
most number of questions.  Which
is doubly amazing because I
think it's after midnight now in
India.  So, this is pretty
amazing.  So, the question is, I
want to know what the best
laptop is for developing Flutter
apps?  You know, which are
compatible with all the
emulators and so forth?
Probably whatever laptop you
have.
That's right.  Yeah.
Yeah.  So, Flutter, part of
being open, you know, when the
team says "Open," they really
mean  it.  They don't just mean
open source.  You should be able
to use the machine that you
have.  Use the tools that you
already like and things like
that.
So, if you're building Flutter
apps,
you can -- you know, this is
IntelliJ ID that I use.  And
runs on everything.
Windows, Linux, OSX.  You can
run --
Apple, yeah.
They -- you can run this on
Chromebooks.
And Chromebook as well.  And so,
if you're -- if you're going to
actually build and release an
iOS app, you would actually need
a Macbook or an Apple machine at
that point because their tool
chain runs on their machine.
So, if you want to actually
build an IPA and sign it and do
all that, at that point, you
would need an Apple machine.
But you could even build it out
entirely without touching a
Macbook or an Apple, you know?
Right.
So, yeah, really, it's -- it's
up to you.
That is one of the advantages of
Flutter is that you can actually
build an iOS app not on a Mac.
And then at the last moment,
because
of Apple's requirements, yes,
you have to find a Mac somewhere
and do the release build.  But
that's it.  And send it off to
Apple that way.  So, you know,
if you have a cousin who has an
Apple laptop.
Just drop by, release your app.
Yeah, just borrow it for a few
hours and there you go.  I'm
going to switch over.  We have
so many live questions coming
in.  I'm going to go ahead and
do a couple of live questions.
Sure.
One is, can I use a Java library
in Flutter?
Sure.  Yeah.
So, Flutter has a thing called
platform channels that can help
you with this.  Let me pull it
up.  We'll go into the laptop
here.
Okay.
Let me do platform channels.
See if I can find it in one
stroke here.  There we go.
So, platform channels is a way
for the dark code in your
Flutter app to talk to platform
code and interact with native
APIs if you want to or just use
the native code.
And so, you can set up a method
channel that will marshal data
sort of into platform land where
you can call Java functions, you
can interact with
the Android API or pull up a
Kotlin code
or an iOS you can call into
Objective-C and Swift and work
with those APIs.
If you have a Java library that
you or your business or your
group has invested a lot of time
in and it would be a little bit
difficult to rewrite in Dart
natively for Flutter, you can
build a
platform channel to it and use
it that way.
You have that ability.
Okay.  Let's go to a related
question.  This one, where is it
coming from?  Let me see?
It's -- this is coming from Lake
Zurich which is actually in the
United States.  In Illinois.
Right.
It's one of our very few US
questions.  So, the question is,
how secure is a platform
channel?  You know, is there any
chance that --
Oh, sure.
That somebody could intercept
that data, especially if they
have a rooted device or
something like this.
This was something I was talking
to the engineering team about
the other day.  So the way
platform channels works, it's --
you have in your application,
you have sort of the Flutter
code is running in Dart.  It's
built with Dart, compiled in
native code and run that way.
And on the side you would have
some of the code that's running,
you know, in Android.  You would
have the Java that's running.
And iOS you have your platform
code for iOS that's also running
outside of that library made
from the Dart.  And so, there's
a memory buffer in your process
for the communication between
the two of them.  And that's --
but that's within your process.
So, there is no, you know, IPC,
interprocess communication
required.  Nobody is writing for
like a named file or a named
pipe on the system to talk
between two different processes
where in theory somebody might
have a
better way to go in and sniff
the traffic or something like
that.  This is all in one
process.  The Flutter app in
that
regard is the same as any normal
Android or iOS app.
Okay.  So, I have another live
question, just came in.
Okay.
can I use a third-party ad
network in my Flutter project?
You're talking to the right
person.  Before coming to the
Flutter team, I worked on the
mobile ads team.
I gave that one just for you.
So, there is an -- there are two
ways that you could do this.
One is, you could use platform
channels to interact with that
network's mobile SDK.  So, if
you wanted to incorporate the
audience network or something
from both or Imobe or something
like that, you could take that
SDK, build a little bridge to
call the platform channels to
call methods on it and access it
and use it as you would
otherwise normally.  The other
option that you have and,
you know, I would make sure that
you test this thoroughly because
it's not something I've tested
personally.
You can use the ad mop function,
it has mediation to use multiple
ad networks in concert.  It sort
of manages which network shows
an ad based on which one is
providing the most revenue at
that particular moment.
And because the plugin for admob
is
using the native Google mobile
ads SDK, that is available to
you.  So, if you have a mediated
ad unit, give it a try with that
plugin and see how it goes.  I
think it will more
than likely work fine.
Okay.  Let me ask another live
one.
Okay.
Can Dart be a standalone
programming language?
Dart is a standalone programming
language.
It absolutely is.  Yes, it can.
Yes, it is.
Obviously on the Flutter team,
we talk about Dart mostly in the
scope of mobile applications.
That's what we use it for.  Dart
for the web.  It's Angular Dart,
it's being used all over the
place.
Our own website, the pub
website, is using Dart to build
-- on the server to build the
website as well.
Yeah.
And we have Euro, he's here, his
application shares Dart code in
between a mobile application
built for Flutter and an Angular
Dart application as well.  So,
that's definitely  possible.
There's also server-side Dart.
There are people building server
applications with Dart.  It's a
very portable language.
That's right.  Okay.
I think I'm going to  ask --
hold on.
Let me find this new one coming
in over here.  Ah.  So, we have
a couple of questions that are
sort of related.  They're saying
at one end of the spectrum is
how do I get started?  Flutter?
Okay.
And we have one question that
said I know JavaScript.  Can I
learn Flutter and Dart very
easily with it?  And at the
other end of the spectrum, how
do I become an expert in
Flutter?
The two, how do I get on the
path and at the end.
I did that, because I just
noticed --
Over there.  Yes.  Please.  You
would be great for this
question.  Please, come and join
us and sit down.
Join
Hi, guys.-the microphone there.
>> This is Pooja, everyone.
Hi, everyone.
You recently wrote an article
about your
path from a complete Flutter
newbie to a seasoned coder,
right?
Yes.
For the person who asked about
getting started, how did you get
started?
I actually got started because I
joined this company.  They
wanted me to work in Flutter so
I learned Flutter.  That's how I
started.
But I will tell you how I
started with Flutter.
What I did is that I worked on a
lot of designs.  You know?  I
mean, Flutter is so great for
designing apps.  I wanted to
lets just redesign app that I
have, that I know.  Let's
redesign it in Flutter.
That sounds like a problem.
It's so easy, you want to redo
everything.
I wanted to see if Flutter has
the capability to actually make
it possible for me to redesign
all my favorite apps.  And I
could actually make apps in one
day.  Like the entire app in one
day.  All the screens and
everything.
And that's -- that's how I was
very sure:  This is it.  This is
what I want to do.
That's right.
I mean, I switched -- I did not
switch.  But I did kind of go
from Android to Flutter because
of  it.  Because it's so amazing
to work with Flutter.
And it's not like those Android
skills aren't used.  You need
them, right?
You still need them.  You can
start Flutter without Android,
but you have to come back to
Android at some point if you
want to work with native
channels.  If you want to make a
fuller app.
You have to know a bit of
Android or iOS.
That definitely helps.
So, what were -- what were some
of the things that helped you
when you were getting started?
So, we talked a little bit about
what you were working on.  Did
you look for articles?  Did you
look for videos?  Did you look
for sample code?  You know,
those sorts of things
I actually looked -- first I
went to the code labs.  Okay.
So, I checked out the code labs.
It was actually very epihadful.
I wanted to try out the Java to
Dart code lab just to see how
Dart it is -- how Dart is like.
And it's pretty easy.  Actually
I learned that in a day.
Once you get past seeing this
and a  constructer, it's fine.
It's actually pretty easy.  I
don't know.  Other languages,
JavaScript, whatever, they're
not so easy.  So, yeah, so, I
was convinced that day.
And I did try out some articles.
Thoughts and the Google I/O.
Flutter.io, docs and code labs.
And there are a lot of GitHub
repositories out there.
And a lot of other tutorials.
And YouTube.
And they all help you a lot.
I'm writing tutorials on Flutter
right
now so you can check them out in
Medium if you want to.
Absolutely.  Yeah, one of the
problems we have as the Dev
team, it's hard to keep up with
the content being made by the
community.  Our GitHub repo with
samples actually links out to a
number of samples that our team
didn't create, we just think are
really, really good.
You should check that out
because they have created the
best resources that's possible
for you to learn Flutter.  So,
check that out.
And it's really great having
people in the community writing
articles.  I remember at one
point where I felt like I had to
write all the articles.  But
then it got to the point where I
was trying to read all the
articles that would be written.
I've totally given up on that.
There's so much coming out.
Same here.  In the beginning, I
used to read all the articles
that used to come.  Now I think
I missed out almost 50%.
It's kind of like all
bookmarked, bookmarked,
bookmarked.
If I have time, I'll read them
then.
Tell us a little bit about what
you're working on right now.
So, right now it's not like a
project.  But I am going to go
back to India and I'm going to
give a talk at a college and
tell them about Flutter.
Because it's pretty -- very,
very required for college people
to actually know about Flutter.
Because you can't actually tell
the employees, but it depends on
the company, what they're using.
But college students, they are
going to graduate with that
knowledge.  And they are going
to tell other people to try it
out.  So, let's start with the
colleges first.  As a college
student myself, I'm targeting
the college student in India.
If you are wanting me to talk
about
Flutter in any of the colleges
in India, hi.  So, yes.
That's what I'm going to work on
now as soon as I go back to
India.
so, almost out of time.  But one
more quick question.  You
watched the keynote.  What was
your favorite thing in the
keynote?
The Square.
The puzzle?
I was really shocked.  I was
really shocked working with
Square right now.
And also the  2Dimensions thing.
Oh, my god.  That was crazy.
Yeah, yeah.
Honestly speaking, this was
really the best keynote because
every five minutes I was like,
what's?
I'm glad you enjoyed it.
Yeah, they put a lot of effort
into it.
We're going to move on to some
more questions.  Thank you so
much for sitting down with us.
We appreciate it.
You are doing a great job.
Thank you for letting us drag
you up here.
Take the microphone with you.
Thank you so much.
We have some livestream
questions.
We're going to take a short
break and then have Eric Seidel
from the engineering team who
you saw in the keynote.  But we
have a little more time.  A few
questions from YouTube.  You
want to look at the livestream?
Do that?  And while you're
looking up questions on there, I
have a couple more coming in.
Here is good one.  I can answer
this one.  We have a question
from Nebraska, from the US.
Says, is there something similar
to build flavors in Android.
And it's true.
Okay.
You can do build flavors.  It's
not really built into it, but,
for example, one of the
developing
companies that I work with is
called app Tree.  And all of
their stuff is in flavors.  They
have an app which they build a
flavor for every single
customer.  That's pretty far
out.
Wow.
And they have, I don't know, I'm
not even sure I can say how many
customers they have because it's
not public information.  But
they build for  company -- for
places like Stanford, for
companies like McDonald's.  They
build an app.  And they have to
customize it for every single
customer.  And they do that with
flavors.  So, you could
definitely do that.  And the
other thing that's amazing
about what they do, they not
only do that on Android.  They
do that on iOS and they do that
on their web app.  So, all three
of them.  They have to deliver
all three to every customer and
they have to have a separate
flavor for it.  So, it's
definitely possible.
They have put out some open
source code, too, right?
What?
They put out open source code.
They have articles.  I'm not
sure if they have written an
article about doing flavors yet.
Maybe we can talk them into it.
Anyway, did you find something?
Let's look at this.  We have
some things in here.  And let's
take a look at this.  So, when
are you planning to support AR
or VR development?
Somebody from the Dominican
Republic.
Augmented reality and --
I think that one's a little bit
down the road.
I think so too.
I think there's other things
sort of before that one.
Part of the reason for that is
so far Flutter is really
concentrating on 2D graphics.
And in order to do AR, I mean,
you can do it with a certain
amount of 2D
graphics, but it really works
better with 3D.  Because you do
need to be able to do
perspective and stuff like that.
So, I think that's probably
something that will happen.  I'm
just not sure when.
It's not on our roadmap right
now.
Let me see what else we have.
Can I integrate my existing
Android project with Flutter?
Can you?
You can.  Many people have done
this.
That's true.
Yeah.  This is something that's
being worked on right now.  But
you can go and look at it.  Add
to an application.  A number of
people with larger applications
have found ways to integrate a
single Flutter activity into
their app.  You can also have a
Flutter activity in Android that
launches a native activity, a
platform activity.  You can show
the platform that way.
And similarly on iOS, you can
have a view control that's doing
Flutter launch, launch a
platform one or vice versa.
And backing up a little bit,
there's
sort of two ways to go about
doing that.  One is, can you add
Flutter to an existing
application.  And you've talked
to that.  But actually another
way to look at it is that you
can actually convert the entire
application to be a Flutter
application.
But then plugin native code from
both platforms into it.  So, you
could either do it as, all
right, here is just a piece of
Flutter as a single view.  Or
you can say, okay.  The whole
thing is Flutter, but we're
going to put a lot of native
code.  They're both good ways to
do it.
The latter is actually easyier
in some ways even though it
seems harder.  It's easier
because you have two separate
applications.  You have an iOS
and an Android app and you have
to put Flutter into both of
them.  Do that two different
ways and you no longer have a
cross-platform solution.  You're
going to be modifying two
different codebases at the same
time.  Whereas if you go the
other way, the code that you
haven't
written in Flutter stays the
same.  But you can just feed
that into a single application.
So, they both work.  That's
probably more detail than people
need.  But anyway.  That's okay.
It's something you can  do.
For more information on this,
you can check out the GitHub,
Flutter/flutter is the repo with
the  SDK.
And you can actually go in and
look at how add to app is
progressing.  They're trying to
make it as easy as possible to
mix native with Flutter.  And
look for add to app and you can
find the code that's being
worked on right now.
I think we're out of time now.
I think we're out of time.  So,
we're going to take a quick
break.  We're going to take a
few minutes break.  And when we
come back, we're going to
have five minutes with Eric
Seidel from the keynote.  Go
ahead and get the questions
down.
Send them to Twitter.  I'm going
to be looking through Twitter.
We picked out a few from
earlier, but if you have them,
get them in and we'll see you in
a few minutes.
All right.
We're back and here with Eric
see dell, one of the founders of
the project here to answer some
we questions.  And I have more
questions.  We are looking at
the screen.  Let's start off.
Can you tell me a little bit
more about the Flutter origin
story.  I told people, Flutter
started as a quest for speed.
I would love know I'm not lying.
No, that's right.  Flutter
started as a quest for speed.
Flutter was a cut down version
of  Chrome.  And we just allowed
ourselves to break with the web
and chop out lots of stuff and
see how fast we could go.
Things in there for old
standards?  Compatibility with
other things
All sorts of things.
The thing that we built wasn't
able to render web pages.  We
ran benchmarks and they were 20
times faster.  So, we knew we
had something there.
You had a rendering engine and I
heard there was a search for a
language at that point.  Can you
tell us about that?  At one
point, Flutter was written in
JavaScript, is that right?
That's right.  We went through
several iterations.
We had a rendering engine in C++
and then more and more
JavaScript code.  And eventually
we had trouble with the
JavaScript code.  We went
searching for another language.
And then eventually all the C++
died away, or most of it.  And
once we found Dart and worked
well for us.  We wrote more and
more and more Dart code.
Where did Flutter, the name,
come from?  I saw that in the
stream earlier.
Where did the name Flutter come
from?
We have heard this story before,
but it's so good.
It turns out naming is is really
hard.  So, we did these things
called trademark searches where
you make sure you can use the
name in various countries and
all that.  And they're not cheap
and they take a long time.  And
we did a bunch of them.  And we
didn't find any names that we
liked that we could use.  And
so, we got a little desperate.
But it turns out that Google has
a
cache of names that they've --
from companies that they've
bought.
Acquired companies.
Or they turn down a name for
whatever reason.  That's where
Flutter came from.  It was a
small startup that they had
bought.  And the product had
turned down, but the name was
still there and that's how we
ended up being Flutter.
That is wild.  All right.  We
have another question here.
This one comes from Twitter.
The account is from Romania.
So,
Buenos cera.  Talk about Dart
and how Flutter influenced Dart
2.0.  Was there things that
Flutter needed from Dart that
the Dart team said, yeah, we can
put those in the language for
you?
Oh, totally.  There's so much
that's been added to Dart in the
last few years specifically for
Flutter.
A trailing comma for the
formatting, the into double.
That's right.
The IoT support in general.
That was a huge thing for the
Dart team for Flutter.
Performance enhancements.  Yeah.
Just lots and lots of work
that's gone into Dart to make
Flutter awesome.
Awesome.  Okay.  Let's see.  So,
with one comes also from
Twitter.
This is from Terra, will Google
introduce a Flutter
certification program similar to
ones that exist for Android?
You know, so, I've heard that
there are these other
certification programs for some
of the other products, which is
awesome.  I think that those are
things that we would think about
a little bit later on.  I mean,
we just had one today.  So, I
think that's a good idea.  But I
think that's probably going to
take a little while.
Okay.  Cool.  All right.  And
this is one last one, sort of a
general question for a lot of
the people watching.
You know, how can someone
looking to contribute to Flutter
best make an impact?  So, if
you're watching this and you're
like, you know, I really like
Flutter.  I like this community.
I would like to be part of it as
a contributor.  What are some of
the best waying to do that?
So --
Other than the fact that you're
hiring, right?
Ed that true.  We are always
hiring.  We have tons of open
positions.  To contribute to
Flutter.  We have a bunch of
documentation on GitHub about
exactly this.  There's lots of
ways to contribute beyond just
engineering.  There's tons of
triage to do.  There's obviously
all these people running events
today, that's contributing to
the system, right?
So, yeah, there's lots of
engineering-specific tasks that
are listed on  GitHub.  Bugs to
fix.
We even have an easy fix label
to help with early bugs.
There's contributing docs on the
engine side for those who like
C++ as well as the Flutter
framework side for those who
like Dart.  There's lots of docs
up on GitHub about exactly this.
Yeah.  And, of course, we have
the package ecosystem and all
sorts of stuff, right?
Yes.
Okay.  Excellent.
So, that's about all our time, I
think.  Any other questions for
Eric we want to touch
That's all I want to ask.
That's our time.  And thank you
for talking to us and talking on
the stream.  Enjoy Flutter Live.
And you can take that with you
and exit right over there.
Thank you so much.
Well, I've got a couple of
questions.
What else do we have?
Well, let me ask this one.
This is a question that says,
can we
design and develop apps for
eCommerce businesses with
Flutter?  This is one of those
questions where I didn't have to
pate person to ask this or I
would have.
Yeah, the answer is people are
already doing  it.  Right?
That's right.
You know, Alibaba.
Yeah, Alibaba is one of the
largest E Commerce companies in
the world and they're using
Flutter for their app.
Absolutely.  We have a sample.
That's right.  Can we see that?
Yes.  If you watched the
keynote, you already saw it a
little bit.
Let me go ahead and pull up --
That's right.  When Will got up
and talked about Material
design.
And has an eCommerce app built
into it.
We have in -- the Material team
built several samples to show
off what Material could do.
The new stuff launched in I/O18
and how to put it to work in
Flutter.  And one of the demos
is Shrine, which is a shopping
app.  So, we took the work that
they did.  Hey, let's put a
little state management into
this and made a model with it
and put a shopping cart into it
and put it on the DevRel samples
repo.
It's up at Flutter/samples.
Look for Shrine.  You can
download that right now.  And
there we go.  Just about done.
This is an example of an
eCommerce app.  So, I can just
flip through next here and go
right on.
So, we have a list of products
just like you would expect.  I
think Will is himself -- yes.
He is in here himself as a
model.
Because we needed a model today,
I guess, for the photos team.
And so, you can click on things
to add them to your shopping
cart.  And you can see the
Material team has put a lot of
time into this.
The expanding bottom sheet of
what's in the cart.  I
know they're proud of it.  It is
so cool.  Add things like that,
click on the bottom sheets and
it expands into the carts.  I
can come in here and take things
out of it.  There's a model,
managing state of what's in the
cart.Tallying up things.  But,
yeah.  Obviously eCommerce is a
huge sector of the mobile app
ecosystem.  It's very important.
So, certainly Flutter, the team
had that in mind as they were
building everything out for
Flutter.  And -- yeah.
Works great.  What else we got?
Got some live questions.
Okay.
Let me pick one.
Is there a way to embed native
UI?  And the example they use,
can I put Apple Pay into an app
and have a Flutter
button that invokes Apple Pay?
Sure.  Yeah, we can talk a
little bit about that.
The Google Maps plugin you saw
and Filip demonstrated.
That's using something called
platform view.
There's an Android and UI view.
And these are the widgets that
manage the native platform view
and sort of fit it into the
world of Flutter.
And so, those are available.
You can go and try them out on
your view and see how that goes.
There's a bit of the cost to the
work you have to do under the
hood.  Don't just throw 30 of
them into every Flutter screen
that you have.  That wouldn't be
a good implementation.  But if
you have one specific view that
you really need to have, like a
control that you've invested a
lot of time in  building or
something from the platform.
You really need a particular
piece of the platform.  Those
have been added now and you can
start putting them to work in
your Flutter apps.  The platform
views.
I have another question.  This
is from Seattle.
Oh.
So, another question from the
US.  They're wondering if there
are any
continuous integration and
continuous deployment options
for Flutter apps?
So, I think we got scooped a
little bit by the keynote.  So,
in the keynote, you saw their
solution for this.  They
partnered.
This came in after the keynote.
Maybe they wanted to know what
the whole  landscape was.
For our DevRel samples, we use
Travis.  It's great for open
source projects.  And it works
great with Flutter.
There's also Cirrus, I believe,
the engineering team uses for
the SDK its.  They have advanced
use cases for testing.  And they
found that fits their particular
needs.  But the tools for
Flutter.
They run on Linux, they run on
the command line.  You can run
tests from the command line very
easily.
They fit very well into CI/CD
systems.
All right.  I don't think that's
a problem at all.  And I'm sure
there's going to be additional
ones.  One thing that we keep
wanting to point out, if there's
something that you want that is
not available yet, you can
actually go in and file an issue
with Flutter.
That is true, yeah.  You have
access -- it not only is Flutter
open in terms of the code and
able to see it, it's developed
in the open.  You can actually
go in and look at what the team
is working on.
You can do it yourself.
You can also do that.
Yeah.  That's good.  Well,
here's a short one.  How about
Dart on the server side?
We are -- we kind of already
touched on it.
I know, we already touched on
that.  But, yes.  You can see
that.
I want -- I said that question
just because I wanted to
emphasize that Dart is a general
purpose programming language.
It does  run -- as you said
earlier, we are focusing on
mobile apps right now.  But
there are people who use Dart,
including us, on the server.
Who use it for web apps and so
forth.  And you have seen some
that have come out this time.
And I think it's only going to
get better.  And in fact, you're
going to start
seeing it on more and more
devices as well.  In fact, you
know, let me continue with this
one.  Here's a question from
India.  It says, what are the
new widgets that are about to
come out in the next Flutter
update?  I love that.
Sure.  Let's touch on this.
Let me go into our -- so, the
easiest way to know -- we get
this a lot.  What's the team
working on?  What's coming out
soon?
The easiest way is to bypass us
and go straight to the team
itself through GitHub.
If I go to the main Flutter repo
here.
You'll notice, open issues for
feature requests and bug fixes.
But the projects tab, which the
team uses.  And you can see what
they're working on sort of in
real-time.
The  IoT plugin, a lot of stuff
with Cupertino.  The energies
working on that.  And add to
app, you can see it's nearing
the end of its sprint.  And some
other things.  You can come in
and see what the team is working
on and that might well answer
your question.  If you don't see
the thing that you think is
really important, there's likely
an issue open for it already.
If not, you can create one.  If
there is one, go ahead and put
comment on it.  Say, I'm
building with Flutter.  This is
important to me.  I need it for
this use case.  You
can put a thumb up on it.  The
team really loves that feedback.
They like getting that and feel
like they're staying close to
what the community needs.  It's
very valuable for that.
I'm going to change gears just a
little bit because I just
noticed somebody standing
nearby.
Okay.  Who have we got?
The question is, what is the
best way to achieve state
management in a Flutter app.
And --
That's Filip.
Let me finish the question.
They're currently using scope
model.  But it seems like it is
maybe not the best fit for their
app.
Okay.
They want to know, what is the
right thing to do.
Fill I, come join us.  You are
the perfect person for this one.
Fresh from the keynote, this is
Filip, everybody.
I think they already know him.
Careful, I think you might have
kicked a video cable.  You're
going to make all the guys in
the back go nuts.  Actually, I
think it did just disconnect.
So, the question from somebody
using scope model.  But they
said it's maybe not the right
fit for their app right now.
And I know state management is a
mission of yours.
Yes.
How do you get to scope model in
the first place?  And then what
might you go on to after that?
FILIP: Yeah, I think a lot of
people are
asking for state management all
the time.  That's a good
question.  It always depends on
many things.  It depends on the
app.  It depends on the team.
And, you know, like previous
experience, all that.
I think if you're -- like, I
think scope model is a really
good start.  And for many
people, it's -- it is what they
need.  Because, you know, it's
-- I think it's pretty simple to
understand.  It gives you all
the things that you want.
It is a little less reactive
than maybe some people would
want.
So, a lot of people will kind of
use
something like, you know,
interactive extensions.  And
maybe some people are super into
redux.
And then we have a flood of
redux package from the community
for the build.  So, I mean, it
depends on what you
want, what your input are and
stuff like that.
I think it really just depends
on what are the patterns you
have used before and enjoy, you
know?  I think that is one of
the biggest factors.
If you have used redux in the
past and loved it, nothing wrong
with using redux.  It works
great with  Flutter.  If you're
used to streams, block,
things like that are very good.
FILIP: Yes.  And I would be
really interested to know what
are the limitations that this
person sees?  Because obviously
there are things that  could,
you know, like, for example,
scope model doesn't really work
that well with streams, I guess.
Because it notifies -- it
rebuilds
widgets sort of in its own way
rather than providing streams
like block would.
FILIP: You can still use it.
But it kind of feels dirty to be
listening to stream and then
notify listeners.  So, anything
is possible.  Yeah.  I guess I
don't have a single answer for
that.
Which is fine, right?
Do you think in the future there
might be different ways of
managing state we don't know
about yet?
FILIP: Sure.  I'm always
researching it.  And last week I
found out that there's a new
thing that is pretty impressive.
It's not completely baked  yet.
But, you know, it's always
something new.
And I think Flutter is very
young.
So, it will have these kind of
like a
plethora of different ways to
manage state.  And in the end,
like many people would tell you,
you know, state management is
building your app, right?
Like next to Azure you will
build your layout and stuff like
this.  But it's also after that,
it's, how do I manage the state
of the app?
And so, you could go all the way
from, you know, just using state
and stateful widgets, which I
don't recommend.  But it can be
--
You can go a long way just with
stateful widgets and rolling
your own.  That's not
necessarily a bad way to for a
lot of people sort of onboarding
themselves with Flutter.
FILIP: Yeah.  I think what we
are not doing a really good job
at is that many people will
just, you know, start Flutter.
They will see the clicking app
where you increment the counter.
And they  think, oh.  This is
how -- this is the way you
manage state.  And that's true
for a single widget.  But it's
often not true for the app.
Right, right.
FILIP: And we're not doing much
to like tell people, like, yeah.
Maybe at least do something with
scope model, right?
Yeah.  And I was actually
talking to somebody earlier and
they were -- they made a point
and I think I agree with them.
But I wanted your opinion on it.
They said that Flutter sort of
takes things far enough that we
can actually invent new types of
state management that are
specific to Flutter and to Dart.
FILIP: Right.
Because of the characteristics
of Dart being functional and
having extremes and things like
that.
FILIP: I was recently last week
I was talking to a person who
came from Android, right?  And
for many people like that -- for
me, when I came to Flutter
through, you know, reactive
programming, it is kind of a
change of mind-set.
Right.
FILIP: And so, again, we
probably should be more better
at explaining like, okay.
So, for example, it's not a big
deal if you rebuild the whole
app once in a while.
It's like, you know, for an
Android
person, for example, like me
like many years ago.
A few week ago?
FILIP: You're not -- I hope that
you're not re-creating the whole
UI from scratch.  But in
Flutter, sure.
Right.
FILIP: That's what you do all
the time.
So, we need to let you go.  But
we did have one question that
came up I think from --
Ah, yes, important question.
They have requested that they
would love to see the source for
your timeline app if it's at all
possible.
FILIP: I have to say, it's not
just mine, it's also
2Dimensions.  And we are going
to release it.  But right now
it's a little bit ugly.  So, we
want to like make it a little
nicer first.
It was that like last minute
crunch that kind of killed --
So, what you're telling us, it
will be available.  You're just
not telling us when.  But
hopefully soon.
FILIP: Yeah, hopefully soon.
>> Thank you very much. Please,
take the microphone.  Thank you
for coming out.
Well, do you have any livestream
questions.
Yeah, let's take a look at the
livestream here.  People
recommending their favorite
approaches to state management.
Yeah.
Yep.
That's good.
We'll have people sort of
arguing for different forms of
state management.
How does Flutter compare to
React native?  Something we have
heard.  Excellent question.
So, you know, it is really
important to
compare different products to
know their
-- but what I worry about is
sometimes it turns into an
argument about what's better and
I don't think that helps
anybody.  Me personally, I think
React native was actually a
brilliant thing for them to do.
They took something that was
made for the web, you know,
React and they said, hey.  We
could take that technology and
apply it to native apps.  And
that's a brilliant thing.
Flutter is similar in some ways
in that we're also reactive.
But it's also solving a slightly
different problem.  And I don't
expect React Native to go away.
I wouldn't tell people, if
you're in React Native, just use
Flutter.  They're for different
things and this is a good thing.
You were talking about this
similar thing the other day.
This question comes up a lot.
Obviously we believe in Flutter
and
the SDK and what it can do and
that it can play an important
role in software and helping
people.  But it's still just one
more tool in everybody's tool
belt.  The fact that Flutter
exists doesn't
mean that React Native is not a
good way to make apps.  For many
developers it is.
Android and iOS didn't stop
being good ways to create apps.
Flutter is another way to do it.
We think it's a really good one.
That's it.  It's two positives.
So, I've noticed some other
people standing by.  Say, we've
got several questions that
came from people that to me are
more questions about the
community.
So, for example, one person
asks, when are their going to be
a way to play sounds in Flutter
and stuff like that.
There is a way to play sounds in
Flutter.
There are plugins in the pub
directory for  playing sounds.
And as far as I know, they were
all written by third parties.
The community, open source
developers.  And we have one
right here.  I see him.  Come
on, Simon.  So, some of you may
know this man.  This is our next
guest.  This is Simon Lightfoot,
a London local.  How are you?
Good, thank you.
Welcome to London.
Thank you.
We were just talking about the
community.  Can you talk a
little bit about your
involvement with the community?
We've done a lot to solve --
build the online conversation
that Flutter has invoked in
everyone, I think.  We have
started up the study group and
we have the Flutter convincing
Medium.
That's right.
And we want everyone to publish
and submit articles and we'll
review them,
edit them and send them out on
the schedule which really helps.
Making sure that everyone's
getting information about
Flutter that everyone really
needs.  Sort of get going
immediately.
How do we let the community know
that, you know, they shouldn't
ask us when is Google gonna
build this or that?  You know,
this is going to succeed if we
all work together on things like
that.
This is it -- what we've seen,
especially with what we have
started up is the Flutter
community GitHub organization.
Right.
And what we've done is, any of
these
projects that the community had
built that want to be owned by
the community.  All right?  So,
this sort of covers that
scenario
of a developer who wants to
maintain their open source
project.  They started up with
an idea, I want this on my
Flutter app.  One app, now it's
out there.  Who is going to
maintain this product?
People submit PRs, people submit
fixes.  No one's merging them.
So, we're here to help.
That's great.  That's an awesome
thing to do.
Well, I see another -- do you
mind if I swap you out?
See you guys later.
By the way, thank you so much,
Simon.
We have another community
member.
Yes.
This is Hilal, thank you.
Internet, Hilal, Internet.
Nice to see you.
When I saw you, I was happy, you
are the
-- can you tell us about your
widget?
It's an open site for listing
Flutter apps.  Any developer
over the world is free to
publish their app.  Doesn't need
to be in the app store.  Doesn't
need to be open source.  If
you're proud of something you
built, showcase it and submit it
to the site and we will show it.
And we all need a place to do
that  occasionally.  You about
something we have built.
So far, about 200 apps.  On
Flutter, there are thousands of
apps.  To more interesting than
the number is the rate of
growth.  A few months to get to
a hundred, and
100 to 200, half that time.
It's going down.
Absolutely.
You have 200 apps.
What I found interesting, when
an app is
created, it's shared with
Twitter follow earlies.  This
app can't be Flutter.  I go
scrambling and message a
developer.  Every time, it's a
Flutter  app.  And the problem
is, there's no look of a Flutter
app.  A Flutter app can look
like anything.  You're just
limited by your imagination and
the  listing of apps.
Awesome.
So, a new campaign, what does a
Flutter app look like?  Anything
you want.
Absolutely.
What -- you also did a podcast
or started a podcast series,
right?
Initially it was going to be a
podcast.  Thomas Brooke --
Then it morphed into a website.
Pretty much.
Simon was working on a Pod cast
and contributed to the website.
Now it's finished, we are going
back to the podcast idea.
Working on it.  It's been a
great response.
Who have you had on?
Some amazing developers.
Marco, Rohan, and if you go to
ifthetwitch.com, you can see it
at the top right.
Go to the site, anyone can
submit a request to be
interviewed.  And the goal is
just for developers to share
their experiences.  You know,
what their backgrounds are.
What they're learning.
And also share best practices
and tips and tricks.
Actually, we've reached the end
of our second block.  Stay right
here.  And one of the things I
wanted to make sure to mention.
The things that I love about
installwidgets.com, you can see
if it's open source or not, and
the link to the app, it  links
to the source.  Installwidgets.
com, go to the apps, I would
love to see how they did that.
You can see how they did that.
One more thing.
Sure.
These take time and resources,
and I work with  Sham and Dave.
I love you very much.
We work and we collaborate to
work on projects.  Still doing a
lot of Flutter work.  But
helping the community, helping
myself more and it's just been a
great experience.
Absolutely.  It's a lot of fun.
All right.  Thank you so much.
We're going to take another
short break.
When we come back, we will have
Ian Hickson, tech lead for
Flutter, sitting here.
If you would like to ask the
tech lead for Flutter.  Somebody
in the project and done a ton of
the  layering and rendering of
code, get those in now.  Stay
with us, we'll be back in just a
few minutes
.
All right, everybody, we're
back.  Ian Hickson, and a bunch
of questions.
This is from Twitter, from
Islamabad.  Hello, Pakistan.
He wrote a column with unfixed
height and a hundred plus list
aisles is a problem.  Do you
have any suggestions?  I'm
guessing this is a performance
situation.
If you just put a bunch of list
tiles in a column.  There's a
lot of work that Flutter's doing
at that point.
You really only want to be
building the widgets that are
actually on the screen.
That way we don't waste any CPU
cycles building things, laying
them out,
painting them if they're not on
the screen.
Listview.builder, and it calls
for each item.  And won't call
it again unless it changes.
Until it goes off the screen and
then back on the screen later,
call you again.
So, with that, it's not
recycling anything like a
recycler view on Android and a
similar control on iOS.
It's not recycling any widgets,
it's  rebuilding if necessary.
That's right.  We don't need to
keep the  objects around.
Garbage collection makes that
very
effici.  We allocate the objects
and then off screen, we get rid
of them.
Hopefully that helped out.
Here's an interesting one.  This
one comes from Sudan.
So, again.
This is
3Mrab -- hopefully I got a good
pronunciation that have.  Can we
build games with Flutter and
what will be the performance be?
Depends on the game.  Not a 3D
game with Flutter.
Sort of expose 3D.
You can do 2D games.
In fact, one of our earliest
demo was a 2D game.
You may have seen it on the
videos in the keynote today.
The sliding tile game.
That's right.  And also a much
earlier one that we had was kind
of a space shooter game.  That
was also --
We saw that in the keynote.
We don't support that really as
like a first class citizen.  We
don't have a framework built for
that.  But there are frameworks
in the community, the community
has provided, to do exactly
that.
I think floatus rights is one of
them?
I have seen that package.
The performance is fine.  We are
designed to render pixels.
Games do that just like UIs do
that.
Not a difference from the
perspective.
I heard that the release for the
Flutter app is not different
from the typical mobile game.
The way Flutter apps work is
similar to how a unity game
would work.
We literally drive all the
pixels and have the hearts of
the 2D seam which
under the hood is a 3D team.
You leave the stuff that hasn't
changed.
Sort of unity, everything built
on top of the renderer is going
towards the use case of games
and for that.  And Flutter is
mostly towards apps and the use
cases.  That's really
interesting.  All right.  So,
what else do we have?  Here's a
good  one.
This is Brazil.  And it's a
question about when would
you build a Flutter app versus a
mobile-friendly website?
So, what is actually  harder
with HTML, CSS and JavaScript
that would be easier in Flutter?
Like why would you prefer one to
the other?
So, I mean, that really depends
on who your target audience is.
And obviously if you're a big
company writing a big app, might
want to do both.
Have the mobile web app for
those who haven't downloaded
your app.
That's true.
Or who are on a device.  An OS
device or a  laptop.  Whatever.
And you might want your mobile
app for people who want the more
native experience.
With butterfly -- sorry, not
butterfly.  With  Hummingbird we
are maybe going to make that
easier.  See how that goes.
Look forward to that.
I have a couple of questions
that came in.
Fire away.
A couple of live questions.
The first one is, is in the
future,
support for Android or Apple
Watch?
I have no idea.
We could, right?
There's no reason we couldn't do
that.  We're really targeting
mobile right now starting to
look at desktop.
Watches are mobile.
That's true.  One thing we have
done, we have a demo -- very
early demo we did to prove that
we are not fixed to ports, we
have a
second demo which renders UI
literally using polar
coordinates.
Which you have a round clock
face, it's perfect.
An hour long watch.  All
coordinates.
No boxes, just sectors of a
circle and  truncated them as
they go.
Yes.
What we're saying is we're
probably not going to do
something like that, but we
would love it if somebody else
tried it.
I certainly would love
contributions to do  that.  We
don't have anything on the
roadmap.  But we're watching.
It's certainly something,
there's a reason it might be a
good thing to do in this weather
if you can do polar coordinates.
You have one more and I have one
more.  And then let you go.
What's your other question?
My other question is we all know
that Flutter came from Chrome.
And the question was, how is the
original team used their
previous knowledge from Chrome
to build Flutter?
And which features were
inherited from Chrome to
Flutter?  If any?
Well, from the code perspective,
we started.  And basically
decided to leave in code.  I
think there's no code left.  We
literally have no code left.  We
still use the same graphics
engine, Skia.  I think there's
literally nothing else left.  We
don't use the same scripting
engine, not the same text layout
anymore.
But it's fair to say that there
was some
experience that you had with
Chrome that sort of informed how
you built this.
Absolutely.  Look at the
internal style guide on our
Wiki, there's a document that
talks about the design
philosophy.  If you look at some
of the earliest bullet points,
it specifically talked about how
to avoid mistakes on the web
before.  Mentions document.
right, for example.  Avoid
document.right style APIs.
We're very much learning from
that.  We've also hired plenty
of people who
have worked on the Android team
and other platforms.  And we're
using everyone's knowledge like
really trying to learn from all
of our experiences.
That's great.
Yeah, so, we have one more and
then let you get back to
enjoying the party.  What
feedback does the engineering
team most value coming from the
developer community?
Oh, wow.
We asked Eric, what can
developers who want to get
involved do to have a chance at
some really good impact?
Developers that are using
Flutter, what are some of the
things that you need from them?
Feedback.  We love all feedback.
Even positive feedback.
I don't mind if you file a bug,
say we're great.  When you file
a bug, what's useful for us,
make sure there's reproducible
test cases.  Have a piece of
code that we can download and
run that  shows the bug really
clearly.  That's really useful
for us.  If we just have a vague
comment like, hey.  Sometimes my
app crashes.  I don't know what
your app does.  I don't know
what the device that it crashes
on.  I don't know what's going
on.  If you tell me, hey, when I
run this specific function on
a, I don't know, a Samsung G5 or
whatever, it  crashes.  That's
helpful.  I can get the phone,
run that app and test it and try
to fix it.
You have to be able to reproduce
it, in other words.
It is very helpful.  I should
say, if you can't reproduce it,
it's still worth filing the bug.
Because if ten people file ten
vague bugs that all say, hey,
when I do this, it crashes.  We
might notice a pattern.  For
example, there's one bug that
we're still dealing with.  We
haven't figured out what's going
on.  We figured out, it only
happens with
Windows 10 in China I think when
you're
doing a hot reload, something
like that.
But we looked at a whole bunch
of bugs filed at different times
and 90% of them mentioned
Windows.  And 90% of them
mentioned, oh, it's a problem
with China or  mentioned they
were in China.  And then we
noticed, we don't have any of
this bug outside China.  So,
file the bug.  That's the most
important thing.  And then once
you file the bug, if you
can, provide a reproducible
snapshot.
Right.  That's great.  Thank you
so much for sitting down.
Everybody out there enjoyed it.
Head straight out that way and
take the microphone with you.
Good-bye, folks.
Thanks again.  For that was
great.
All right.  Let's do livestream.
>> Yeah, let's look at the
livestream.  We haven't done
much livestream.
We are getting livestream from
Twitter.
Let's get back into the YouTube
livestream.  What do I have
here?
Well, if you're looking for a
second.  I've got a question
that I can answer really fast.
Go for it.
We just had somebody who wrote
in just a few minutes ago.  They
said, is there any chance of
having Kotlin on Flutter?  And I
have a stock answer for that
one.
Which is, if you're willing to
give up hot reload, sure.  But
so far nobody's taken me up for
that.
Stateful hot reload is one of
the features that Flutter can
get that's not
easy to find in other languages.
Hot loading code, or writing
JVM.  Dart is built for that
kind of thing with its just in
time compiler and all that
stuff.  It can still compile the
native code at the end.
So, there is still Kotlin code
in the Flutter app.  If you want
channels, you're not tied to
Java necessarily there.  But the
particular features that Flutter
needs, it really gets from Dart.
Yeah.
There's actually an article that
I  wrote, self-plug right here.
Why Flutter uses Dart.  And if
you're curious about what are
the advantages of Dart, you can
read that.  Search for why
Flutter uses Dart and that will
help answer that question.  Have
you found anything?
Yeah, we have a couple here.
Go for it.
One from Pedro who posted, is
Flutter I/O going to replace
Android?  Well, Android
development --
So, this is just like the
question we answered earlier
when people were asking us about
React Native and stuff like
that.  No, Flutter is not going
to replace Android.
They're different things.
Android is an operating system
and Flutter is a software
development.
Right.  They're not even
related.
They're two different bastions.
And even if you wonder straight
ahead, Android development is
going to be replaced by Flutter.
None of us think that's going to
happen either.  It's not like,
you know, something new comes
along and it gets rid of
something else.  There are
things that Android does really
well.  And that it would be hard
to do in a cross-platform-type
tool.
So, there's definite use cases
that will always be valuable for
that.  So, we can name examples
of  that, but I think they've
gotten the idea.  Let's go on to
the next one.
Yeah, I just skipped past a
question asking about background
tasks and Flutter, things like
that.  Which we can touch on a
little bit.  So, certainly,
again, a Flutter app built for
Android is still an Android app.
And a Flutter app built for iOS
is still just a typical iOS app.
And you can add code to do a
number of things that way on
that -- on the platform side.
We use platform channels to talk
back and forth.
And speaking of back ground
tasks, I was talking with Ben
the other day.
Have you seen Ben's background
task that he wrote about
geofencing?  Schedule tests.  If
you haven't seen it, it's great.
He wrote a very  detailed
example and had source code up
on GitHub for how to
make a Flutter app use
geofencing to do certainly
things in response to GPS
events.
And that's definitely a need for
background pass, exactly.
And he had an app that was
opening his garage home when he
arrived home with his bicycle.
And so, the source for that is
actually on GitHub.  You can do
a search for it.
Geofences and Flutter, you'll
find it.
A great job on the article and
put the code up where people can
see it.  That might well answer
your question and show you how
to get started with that.
Okay.  I've got another question
here.
Okay.
It's from somebody, they're
asking, what are the tools and
what are the processes
I could use to optimize my
Flutter app?  You know, and
they're talking about they were
working on an app.  It took up
more space than they wanted.
And the performance was not
where they wanted.
I just saw Devin.  Perfect.
You saw -- yeah, exactly.  I saw
Devin too.  We actually have the
guy in charge of Flutter
tooling.  Devin, would you come
on up?
We're going to spend a little
time with my  laptop here.  Let
me get back into -- this is just
my Scratch Pad app.  Ladies and
gentlemen, Devin from the
tooling team.  Our Portland
office.
Real quick, what are all the
responsibilities that you have?
What are all the things you
cover in your work?
We cover a bunch of things on
the tooling team.  We make
toolings to plugins for the
major IDE support, IntelliJ and
Android Studio both.  And
virtual Studio as well.  We work
on static analysis tooling.
That is a command line tool and
a language server.  Command line
tools are analyzed.  The
language server is actually
interesting.
It's a separate process which
powers IDEs through a protocol.
It's how we're able to provide
support for multiple IDEs in an
economical way.
We support some other tools like
Dart doc and Dart pad, language
playground.
I use DartPad all the time.  A
lot of the  things we think of
as
making developer's lives
easier, you are the one
overseeing production of those.
For much of it, yeah.
So, I use IntelliJ.  That's what
I like to use.  Let me get an
app going here.  Say it was
misbehaving and I didn't know
why.
It was dropping frames or
queuing up gigabytes of RAM on
my phone and heating it up, I
could fry an egg on it.  What
are some tools to look into to
get a handle on that problem?
That's an area that we have been
working on in the past quarter
or two and going forward as
well.  Performance tooling.  We
want to make it so that when
Flutter was very small, users,
if they had performance
problems, they could come to the
Flutter team and we could solve
their performance problems.
Doesn't quite scale.
As flutter apps gets bigger, we
want them to solve the problems
through good documentation or
good tooling.  And going to the
Flutter website, we have docs
about ways you can make your
apps more performant.
Best practices.  Flutter.io.
There we are.
And we're also in parallel
building out new tooling as well
to help you with that.
And we're concentrating mostly
on UI jank tooling.  So, my app
is missing frames.
Basically to help be better
aware when they're missing
frames.  And if they  missed a
frame, why are they doing that?
And then the other slide is
looking at memory tooling.  Give
people a better use of memory
usage.  Where is it going?
Is it a leak or just a lot of
resources?
So, some of that tooling is
shipped
now and available in IntelliJ
and Android Studio.
And I think I have the latest
version of the plugin right
here.  The latest version of
IntelliJ I just updated.
There's some things on the sides
here I can see.
And what -- where am I going
first?  Find some jank.
So, for performance, you want to
go to our Flutter performance
tab.  It's on the bottom.
It's active whenever an app is
running.  We'll have this
available.  There's some simple
options we have
which are useful that are just
enabling performance features
already in the Flutter
framework.  So, if you toggle on
the performance overlay.
I got some stuff.
And you interact with your app,
you can sort of see your frame
rate.
We have the same information
available inline in Intellij as
well.  Toggle that off.  There's
another one that's useful.  It's
the debug drawing toggle.
It's the I think the  second --
yeah.  Third one.  It just sort
of shows you the outline of your
widgets and gives you a sense.
That's more for layout.
So, if I have something that's
not where it needs to be, I can
quickly come in with this.
It's like border equals one.
It's a sense of the layout.
And we have a Flutter inspector
for very detailed knowledge.
But performance feature we just
launched.
If you want
wanttology off the bug draw.
What we've done is instrumented
your
code at run time to display
inline in
the editor which helps
rebuilding.  It's really like
magical.  If you have been doing
Flutter for a while and haven't
had this feature.  As you
interact, we'll show you which
widgets are  rebuilding.  If
widgets are rebuilding.
Sometimes having them rebuild is
perfectly natural.  But
sometimes you can end up
rebuilding much more than you
expect.  And that could indicate
a performance issue.  Doesn't
mean it is.  But --
So, that was just that little
online 32
I think it was, I saw that text
widget as it was building.
But if you give that a bit more
space at the bottom.  You can
see a table of widget rebuilds.
Oh, wow.
This app is not doing a whole
lot.  If your app was nor
sophisticated, you
would see the widgets that were
rebuilt, how much they were
rebuilt, and double click on
this widget, it would take you
to the source where it was
created.
Actually show the source window.
Yeah.
And there it is.
This was all just launched in
last month's release and this
month's release.
And we actively used a lot of
user studies to tweak this, and
user feedback.  So, this last
release I think the changes we
made were just written by user
studies.  Of  trying to validate
that the tooling we'd shipped
was actually solving the
performance problems.
I mean, the rebuild indication
on the widgets is great, not
only for performance
information, but people learning
Flutter.
It gives you better insight what
your app is doing.  Not
performance-related.  But just
like --
So, let me -- one of the other
questions -- we got this I think
a little bit earlier was related
to Observatory.  Which I think
is at the moment a bit of an
advanced tool.  But can we take
a look at that and maybe you
show me some of the things going
on with Observatory as well?
Well, I think one of the main
features you should use
Observatory for in a Flutter
context is their timeline view.
Which gives a detailed view of
the events that your app is
going through.  And in familiar,
it can help you identify slow
frames and why those frames are
slow.  This is some of the
tooling we're actually
rebuilding to make it more
user-friendly.  Right now it's
the only way, really, to debug
UI jank in your app.  But it's
one of the ones that we want to
make more approachable to your
typical user.
So, if you go into this view
timeline.  And then check all
these boxes.
Okay.
Check those.  Go back to your
application.
Interact with it a little bit.
Click a button or two.  And then
if you go back to the timeline
view.  And choose refresh.
So, in a new version of this
app, you
wouldn't have tokingle those
options on refresh.  It would
just be streaming data live.
But you can now see in the
timeline view -- we don't need
to get into much more detail
than this, but you can see
events for when frames were
created.  When your build method
was running.  What was happening
in that build method.
And basically our -- and
iteration of this, we hope to
make it much more actual for
users, once they see this data,
what does it mean they should do
to their app to make it
performant?  Or is it a
performance problem at all where
they would be optimizing where
it's not really necessary.
I got here think a link in
Intellij.  This is a web server.
Exactly, yeah.
Cool.  Well, I'm afraid we've
hit our time.  We need to say
good-bye to you and answer some
more questions here before we
end our --
We have a couple coming in.
That's good.  Thanks for coming
up.
Thank you so much.  That was
really great.  Devin, everybody.
So, I have a couple of
questions.  First one should be
a pretty easy one.
The question is -- I like the
way they said it.  It's time to
end the debate.  Which is
better?
VSCode or Intellij Android
Studio?
As I think we just saw, all of
those are
supported for Flutter
development by Devin and his
team.  A bunch of engineers
working on them.  They're going
to co-exist.
I think during the keynote most
of the demos were on VSCode.  A
lot of people internal in
Flutter use VSCode.
And Filip liking Android Studio.
I use Intellij.  And people,
engineers on the team, that use
the text editor.
That use VI or Emacs.
Use both.
But yeah.
One of the differences is I
think some of the new features
do appear on Intellij first.
But  they -- they get to VSCode
very quickly.  So, I think, you
know, this is gonna be just like
every other question people ask
us about this.  What's the best?
The best is the one you already
know how to use and just use it.
I happen to use Intellij because
I end up testing a lot of the
new features that come out.  I
actually work with Devin and the
rest of the tooling team.  So,
they always -- they throw a lot
of things at me.  I'm a good
idiot for idiot testing.  But,
you know, it just -- it really
depends on what's important to
you.  But, you know, it really
is up to you what you use.
There's not really a huge
difference between them.  So,
I've got one more that I have to
ask.
All right.  Go for it.
Running out of time.  The
question is, and it's a great
question because it answers
itself.  The question is, how
you pronounce fuchsia?  So --
A question about fuchsia.
That's one of the few questions
about fuchsia we can answer.  If
you don't know what fuchsia is,
it's open source.  You can go
look at it.
It's a about all we can say
about it.
One of the things I like about
an open source project.
I'm not good at keeping secrets.
I don't learn them in the first
place.  Everything with Flutter
is open, don't have to worry
about it.
Anything from the livestream.
We're kind of running out of
time.
We're going to have to let
everybody go in a minute.  Let's
see.
Anything interesting?
A question about accessibility.
That's a big concern.
When I joined the team, one of
my
first meetings on the team was
not an accessibility  review.
But the person who does the
accessibility reviews, they
talked about the tools in
Android and iOS.
And semantic tree in Flutter,
it's in part for accessibility.
It was designed into Flutter
from very early on.  What else
do we have here?  Someone noted
that they're installing Flutter
right now.
Yeah!
Good on you.
You're obviously not here at the
party, then.
Somebody was wondering about
positions.  Which is the widget
-- what?
Positioned.
Which was the widgets I used
earlier.
It's like stack is used with a
row.  With a stack, you're
stacking up children one on top
of each other.
And you use positioned, maybe
you want to have a small one on
top of a big one
and you want it in the
lower left-hand corner or make
it expand and fill the stack.
That's positioned.
Usually it's a first order child
of a stack.  People calling
about issue numbers.
So, they're looking at the --
there's -- somebody's asking
about the impact of Flutter on
the app size.
That is something that matters a
lot.  Certainly in some parts of
the  world.  Right now in
Android, the number is just over
4 megs.
To get just the engine and the
four widgets.  That number was a
lot higher when I joined the
team.  6 or 8.
It was 6.7 for a while.  They
actually had not done any work
trying to get that down.  And
finally, somebody said, let me
play with that a little bit.
And it dropped down to four.
Shrinking.
And they're not willing to say
it would be that hard to do it
even better.  They got rid of
that much just by eliminating
things that were naturally being
generated by the build process
but weren't being used.  They
figured them out and stopped
those from being emitted.  So,
there's almost certainly more
things they can do to get the
space down.  And I know that's
something they're working on.
It's part of the CI process for
the SDK.  Just build an app to
see if they bloated it at all
and look at the metrics every
time they make a change.
Definitely on the team's mind
and something that's very
important.  I think we're going
to be running out of time quite
soon.  Maybe have time for one
more.  Do you have one more from
Twitter maybe we can cover?
Sure.  Can you talk about
artificial intelligence and
machine learning integration on
Flutter?
Sure.  Well, you had a great
demonstration, obviously, with
what you saw on the keynote.
Maurice is working on some great
things.  We're  hopping for the
DevRel sample in Flutter in the
coming quarter in part because
we just really want to build it.
Who doesn't want to build
something like that?  And so,
that's there.
For more advanced ML cases where
you
might want more direct access to
TF-Lite
or for like that, platform
channels is a way to go as well.
We have been saying for a while
now, with Flutter you have a
great degree of freedom to work
with things.  And with platform
channels.  So, if you ever see a
plugin that's not quite your use
case or you don't see a plugin
for a tool that you want to use,
you can always go use it
yourself.  You can always build
this bridge yourself and get
access to it that way.  And when
you do, please post it on
GitHub.
Make a package out of it so the
next person can use it as well.
That's right.  I've got one
more.  What about code push?  Is
there gonna be code push?  Sort
of like Microsoft code push?
Sure.
Might want to define it.  Not
everybody knows it.
Code push is a popular piece of
technology that Microsoft has
made and open sourced, I think.
To push live code to an app that
has been released.  I think with
React Native, for example,
because they're using a JS, you
can push new JS code to the VM
using this.
And so, this is something -- the
way Dart works in debug, you
have a VM and just in time
compilation.
But then when you build for
release,
you're combining a static layer
and not using a just in time
compiler at that point.  It's
not something that's supported
yet.  But I've heard like this
hallway conversation about this.
It's the kind of thing that's
not -- I don't know if it has a
definite place on the roadmap,
but it's definitely in people's
heads and will end up there
soon.
I know people are looking at it.
I don't know if it's on the
schedule yet.  I see they're
going to take a group photo of
everybody who is here, so, I
think this is a great time for
us to say good-bye and get in
the group photo.
So, yeah.
So, obviously we weren't able to
get -- we had a lot of great
questions today.  We weren't
able to get to all of them.
If we didn't get to your
question, we will try too get to
them after the fact.  Answer on
Twitter.  And on YouTube, we
will get it on the boring show
if we can.  That's where we
answer questions and hack on
things.  And I will leave you
with a bunch of resources to
grow as a Flutter developer.
There's a ton made by the
community.  And we have
something to offer you.  The
Flutter samples repo.
We have the docs.
We have the docs, the code labs,
the Flutter cookbook and
Flutter.io.
I think they took their picture.
Oh, well.
You can come join us on Gitter
on our  Flutter/flutter channel
on Twitter, Flutter.io.  We have
a big play list of YouTube
videos like the  boring show.
Speaking of YouTube, I need to
thank the small army of people
behind the scenes who have
helped us put them together.  We
have John and Adam as tech lead
and tech support.  Simon in the
back on audio.  Neil is the
project manager.  Derrick,
Daniel, Luke and Rick, the
social team, Robert, Justin and
David.  Crystal and Phil.  Ashe.
I am Andrew.
Good night from Flutter Live and
great  coding.
We have had a great time.  Thank
you all.